[Musique]
jean daniel oui
ah le voilà
bonsoir
moi là-bas avions un
bon merci non parce qu'on fait de la
télé aussi oui bonsoir bonsoir
écoutez bienvenue au théâtre du rond
point je me présente donc jean daniel
magna je suis le directeur littéraire de
ce théâtre un théâtre qui depuis vingt
ans se dédie aux autres hisser aux
auteurs qui racontent le monde
d'aujourd'hui mais qui est également
programmé beaucoup de débats de
conférences de conférences performances
de forums et donc je vous dis bienvenue
à la cinquième édition du festival nos
disques sont rayés c'est un festival qui
ce qui cherche à explorer en fait nos
blocages
les choses qu'on sait très bien qu'on
doit faire d'urgence et qu'on ne fait
pas par exemple je pense au climat
évidemment
on appelle ça nos dissonance cognitive
mais qui s'intéresse aussi à ceux qui
sont en périphérie dans la périphérie
on appelait ces gens là le peuple on le
croyait disparu il a fait irruption il
ya deux ans sur nos boulevards n'auront
point
est la question qu on va se poser
pendant cette cinquième édition c'est
que demandent les peuples qu'est ce
qu'un peuple
sommes nous le peuple
alors pendant quinze jours des penseurs
des artistes des activistes
des philosophes vont se succéder sur nos
scènes même des stands de peur pour
tenter de répondre à ces questions il ya
un programme évidemment ligne sur le
site du rond point où ce pas
en dire plus mais en tout cas la
particularité de ce festival cette année
c'est qu'on a senti la nécessité
peut-être vu l'ambiance politique
générale de sortir de l'entretoit parce
que souvent c'est des gens qui sont
d'accord sur nos plateaux souvent ils
sont mous finalement tous d'accord le
public est d'accord
sortir de l'entretoit se dire que
finalement ça n'est pas suffisant de
rester fidèle à ses convictions et de
tenir à distance celui qui ne les
partage pas et pour ça je suis très
heureux que frédéric taddéï est interdit
d'interdire est accepté de venir pour la
soirée d'ouverture
je pense qu'on est tous d'accord
connecte à être délié est un as pour
réunir alors j'essaie de le citer des
gens fous qu'on ne voit pas ailleurs qui
sont très compétents qui ont un fort
caractère et qui ne sont pas forcément
d'accord entre eux c'est ça à peu près
et le principe c'est plutôt ça
c'est ce que la voix c'est ce que vous
allez voir ce soir alors voilà je vais
vous donner ma version la version plutôt
d' interdit d'interdire de 2 que
demandent les peuples et alors vous
allez voir une émission de télévision
quand même puisque tout est en direct au
même moment sur les réseaux sociaux puis
il y aura une version qui passera à la
télévision sur rt demain mais donc il
faudra nous excuser si un moyen des
pauses elles seront le plus court
possible 30 secondes mais mais voilà on
a besoin de faire des pauses à
développement pour qu'il puisse y avoir
des bandes annonces ou des publicités
des choses comme ça j'ai pas de
prompteur dont vous allez me voir temps
en temps regarder par terre c'est parce
que mes fiches sont par terre
j'ai la flemme de tous d'apprendre par
coeur et en plus ma vie baissent donc il
faut que ce soit loin donc c'est par
terre donc si je regarde par terre ne
vous étonnez pas et puis à part ça
devrait bien se passer
donc j'espère que ça vous intéresser et
il y en a pour deux heures normalement
vous devriez pas les sentir passer
d'accord j'en suis sûr mais alors là je
retourne là bas vous voyez c'est ça moi
par là ok alors le truc ce sera l'action
le truc théâtrale de la soirée
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
dire mais sur la scène du théâtre du
rond point et en public c'est ici que se
tient jusqu'au 12 février le festival
nos disques sont rayées sur le thème que
demandent les peuples jean daniel magnin
et le théâtre du rond-point m'ont
demandé d'ouvrir le festival avec
interdit d'interdire alors que demandent
les peuples le peuple
existe-t-il sommes nous le peuple autant
de questions que je vais poser à mes
invités que je vous présente tout de
suite en tout cas les quatre premiers il
y en aura d'autres après le ramadan
gauche marcel gaucher philosophes
historiens c'est l'auteur de l'avènement
de la démocratie et de comprendre le
malheur français dont le deuxième volume
est paru récemment chez stock sous le
titre macron les leçons d'un échec
emmanuel todd
anthropologues historiens c'est l'auteur
de les luttes des classes en france au
21ème siècle et où en sont elles une
esquisse de l'histoire des femmes tous
les deux sont parus au seuil
aurélie go maire divers droite de
coudray-montceaux conseillère régionale
d'ile-de-france conseillère
départementale de l'essonne vous avez
fondé la france vraiment qui veut
inciter les citoyens à peser sur le
débat public et à ma droite françois
bousquet rédacteur en chef du magazine
éléments la revue de la nouvelle droite
théorisé à l'époque par alain de benoist
le directeur de la nouvelle librairie
qui est également la librairie de la
nouvelle droite et sa maison d'édition
est l'auteur de courage un manuel de
guérilla culturel et de biopolitique du
grenat virus sous titré télé travail
famille patrie alors commençons tout de
suite
le peuple alors moi la première question
que j'ai envie de vous poser c'est
qu'est-ce qu'on a encore en commun nous
le peuple français à part la langue les
services publics les paysages et le
droit de vote daguerre encore y avait le
service militaire on regardait tous le
même journal de 20h on gardait le même
film le dimanche soir à la télé on était
condamné en tout cas pour ceux qui
n'aimaient pas comme moi entendre johnny
hallyday claude françois
on pouvait pas y échapper je veux dire
mais maintenant mon fils qui a 20 ans il
sait pas ce qui est johnny hallyday il
n'a jamais entendu même alain souchon
il nous reste coi par l'équipe de france
de football en commun c'est le gaucher
plus qu'on ne croit à mon avis il nous
reste beaucoup plus qu'on ne croit ce
qui est
d'abord dans ce diagnostic dans votre
description est très juste mais elle
sous-estiment un autre facteur qui est
la convergence de la société française
par exemple c'est vrai dans tous les
pays d'europe à des degrés divers il y à
une homogénéisation de nos sociétés qui
est très frappante et qui sait que le
besoin de cette culture commune est
beaucoup moins ressenti on n'est plus
dans une société vous avez une classe
paysanne extrêmement
particulière une classe ouvrière très
fermée sur elle même relativement une
classe bourgeoise urbaine très ancrée
dans l'histoire non on est on est passé
dans des sociétés beaucoup plus homogène
du point de vue des référents quotidien
et puis ensuite de quoi
c'est le produit d'une très longue
histoire nous avons en fait une culture
commune implicite qui ressurgit temps en
temps à la faveur d'événements
particuliers le dernier exemple en date
mais très frappant notre dame de paris
l'un s'en dit notre dame c'est quelque
chose qui a révélé que tous les français
quand je dis tout c'est toujours un abus
de langage mais ça veut dire une très
très grande majorité sens très bien
savoir d'où sortait de ce monument ce
qu'il représentait au juste était très
présent dans la conscience des acteurs
un autre exemple qui m'a beaucoup frappé
au moment de la faire des gilet jaune
cette crise
l'enseignement de l'histoire étant ce
qu'il est c'est pas le lieu d'en
discuter mais on sait que les repères
historiques de la plupart des français
d'aujourd'hui sont assez floues on s'est
aperçu que la mémoire de la révolution
française était extrêmement présente
d'une manière très confus sous forme
d'image mais très présente dans la
conscience des acteurs comment expliquer
ce genre de phénomène je pense qu'il ya
eu un glissement la culture commune est
devenue souterraine les touts les la
culture explicite que vous on vous
donnait l'exemple est effectivement
disparu au profit d'une disparité
incroyable mais en réalité il ya une à
six communes et qu'est ce qu'il me fera
beaucoup c'est de voir par exemple
commande chez des populations immigrées
il ya une rapidité dans l'acquisition de
cette culture commune qui est assez
étonnante on aimerait savoir par quels
canaux ça passe mais ça parce que qu'on
pense à autre au plug bas je suis très
gêné parce que je suis d'accord avec
tout ce qui vient d'être dit ces deux
situations je dirais le rhétoriquement
difficile
oui c'est que si on pense en termes de
conscience de soi de la nation on a
l'impression qu'il ya plus rien mais je
vais faire l'anthropologue si on pense
en terme de façon des deux modes de vie
de nos rapports à l'autorité
de mauvaise humeur
je gère les françaises sont toujours les
français en fait techniquement moi j'ai
même gelé plutôt frappé par
l'imagination sur le plan ce qui a été
dit sur les classes sociales est très
vrai évidemment et mais j'ai passé toute
ma vie à travailler sur les différences
régionales en france les différences de
structure familiale
dont la
diversité faisait un peu la magie de la
france avec des conflits qui n'expire
entre l'agent catholique pas catholique
communisme en conviendra ou autre chose
et j'ai fini par admettre ça c'était
dans les deux classes en france mesurée
que même ça c'était avait disparu et
qu'il y avait une organisation
territoriale était tout à fait logique
si on pense en terme de mobilisation par
la télévision parler donc en fait il est
vraisemblable que la france n'a jamais
été aussi homogène et vivent ici et puis
il suffit de sortir de france pour s'en
rendre compte willis leurs seins on
passe la manche qui ont des tailleurs
les lego bas pour compléter les propos
de monsieur gauche et je moi je
qualifierais sa de passion française je
pense que c'est ce qu'on a en commun est
ce qu'on a pu voir notamment au moment
de la crise et gilot john c'est
justement la fraternité qui sert et
exprimer de façon assez incroyable j'ai
été moi personnellement frappé et
beaucoup d'entre nous ont été frappés
par par ces personnes qui se
retrouvaient autour d'un sujet commun
donc je pense que tout ça n'a pas
disparu les français restent les
français ils sont là et je crois qu'il
ya une passion de la france nous dit à
travers certains événements qui peuvent
être tragiques par ailleurs mais les
français ont envie de se retrouver
autour d'un sens et ils sont toujours là
pour se retrouver autour de ce sens-là
envie de se retrouver son pc hassine
nous parlera oui oui on pourrait en
apparence souscrire au tableau que vous
avez livré et quand on en a en tête le
bouquin qui est un livre des plus
importants de ces derniers mois deux cas
céline fourquet sur la france où nos
yeux ou en fait c'est la france d'après
on a le sentiment quand on dit livre que
il s'est produit une mutation
anthropologique
l'américanisation s'est accélérée la
musique country à coloniser la france
périphérique les clubs de biker eux se
sont domiciliés dans toutes les sous
préfectures de france c'est un autre
monde la sociologie des prénoms la
malédiction de kevin est ce que la
france est toujours la france oui bah
comme le dit gaucher oui j'aurais ya des
permanences la constitution mentale des
peuples s'inscrit vraiment dans une
histoire au très long cours et ont pu
vivre ce fil rouge sur 1500 en 2000 ans
quand on lit la guerre des gaules de
césar quitte à surprendre les gens quand
on lit le glossaire de la guerre des
gaules de césar c'est celui de gillet
journée déjà un comportement belliqueux
un comportement un comportement
indiscipliné spirituel c'est déjà la
lecture que donnent les ethnographes
grecque au moins 2e - 1er au premier
siècle avant jésus-christ rebond avant
notre ère donc il ya dans le long cours
de notre histoire il ya des efforts à
venir de n'importe quel peuple
analphabète à l'époque
non je ne crois pas je crois que c'était
vingtaine à des pages magnifiques sur
cet esprit français et gaulois et lui le
montre au long cours en à partir du
12ème 13ème siècle des fabliaux la
révolte la protestation les gilet jaune
contre ça de manière quasiment
chimiquement pur ce comportement
protestataires il a une antériorité
révolutionnaire il s'inscrit dans les
émotions d'ancien régime dont la france
a une histoire le long comme comme comme
paris barcelone donc oui donc le je
crois que de perdure des des traits
constitutifs qui s'inscrit vraiment dans
la très longue durée évidemment quand on
voit les gilet jaune puisqu'on est au
coeur d'une autre sujet le populisme que
feront les gilles et josé ce que dit
fourques et en seine-et-marne ici se
réunissent au rond point devant l'entrée
d'euro disney oui d'accord qu'est ce
qu'ils demandent des filets jaunes
d'oeufs d'euro disney c'est avoir un
ticket gratuit pour rentrer à eurodisney
ou qu'on peut se dire mon dieu qu'est ce
qui s'est passé ils ont été complètement
acculturés n'a pas tout à fait ces deux
le cas johnny l'idée c'est qu'on a
nationalisé cette acculturation quand on
se balade dans la france périphérique
perdure un ce que les sociologues
appellent un capital d'autochtonie faire
quand on s'appelle kevin jordan mais
pour autant dans la sainte barbe des
pompiers chaque année chaque année on
verra galette des rois chaque année on
va à la chasse on va fêter
l'anniversaire au bouffay le grill donc
en effet à la sas l'identité castro
nomique a explosé mais on fait qu'on
fait la cueillette des champignons
donc c'est moi je ne pense pas que ce
soit comportement schizophrène cette
partie des bricolages identitaire
indispensable c'est que
rencontrent sur l'idée que les français
sont juste des gens indisciplinés or là
je repasse en mode
france pas encore homogène sur le plan
territorial ensuite ce sera le mystère
mais plein de trucs qui m'avait beaucoup
frappé qui fera beaucoup les étrangers
sa journée ces américains qui m'a fait
remarquer un jour que assez drôle la
france un pays qui a la foi de la
continuité la flexibilité et c'est que
en fait la france est un pays où
les comportements sont capables d'être
extrêmement anarchique en fait révolte
de refus de l'autorité mais aussi par
moments
extrêmement discipliné ce qu'on ne sait
jamais alors s'est inscrite dans des
cultures régionales au départ mais je me
souviens c'est un truc j'ai l'exemple
que je dis souvent au moment des 195 cas
votre 1995 maintenant il faut préciser
hier autres la jupe est ok mais il ya vu
des reportages de se sait plus quelle
chaîne de télévision en allemagne en
italie et donc les allemands disaient au
racket dix ans en france quel foutoir
enfin qui se sent allemand évidemment et
puis les italiens auxquels discipline
dans cette hydre à l'organisation est
donc enfin c'est pour ça qu'on ne sait
jamais si la france va gagner la guerre
admirablement ou la perdre misérablement
s'il ya un truc que j'ai une sonde
ambivalence dans le système français
général de gaulle disait qu'on était les
meilleurs combats combattants mais il
fallait qu'on soit bien commander
et versa et dans ce que dit emmanuel
todd il ya de
cette dimension assuré qu' sionnel
plébéienne faubourienne dressent des
barricades et parallèlement à ça donc la
discipline parlementaire il ya une quête
en tout cas depuis deux siècles une
quête de l'homme providentiel une quête
du chef qui va donner de donner forme
donner consistance à cette révolte donc
on aussi entre ces deux tempéraments
alors évidemment je suis tout à fait
d'accord dès qu'on parle de psychologie
des peuples on est par définition dans
l'impressionnisme c'est pour pas faire
autrement mais comme vous le rappeliez
il suffit de voir des allemands ils nous
rappellent à ce que nous ça s'est pas
complètement impressionnistes et à
surprendre les structures familiales
quand elle était encore bien définir
généralement il ya tout le bassin
parisien qu avait un type libéral
égalitaire prédisposant à l'anarchie
disent qu'on va trouver andalousie ou en
italie du sud paradoxalement et puis une
périphérie avec des structures sud ouest
à l'instar des structures souches de
type allemand ça peut être décrit en
fait l'articulation des deux c'est le
système france donc c'est pas c'est pas
la psychologie des peuples et là on peut
faire de l'anthropologie
j'ai envie de vous poser maintenant c
est ce qu est une opposition de fait
entre le pays légal et le pays réel le
pays légal ce serait les élites c'est à
dire les élus les riches les médias les
instances européennes qui sont tous à
peu près voue aux gémonies de la même
façon ils seraient tous forcément
déconnecté du pays réel le pays réel et
en lui représentant pas ans présenté par
le peuple c'est à dire une mosaïque de
communautés
qui a quand même soutenu à 75% les gilet
jaune par exemple alors même qu'ils
étaient en train de le feu aux
champs elysées donc là et quand même il
y avait quand même il y avait une
manifestation de quelque chose il reste
75 % d'un côté puis 25% de l'autre côté
qui sera à peu près l'électorat
d'ailleurs d'emmanuel maquereau au
premier tour
il ya
effectivement
deux événements qui ont modifié
profondément la cartographie habituel de
nos repères politiques la mondialisation
d'un côté et d'autre part la montée du
niveaux des ducati fait manuel tonnes
c'est ça mieux que moi qui a produit une
couche sociale de diplômés qu'ils y est
devenu quelque chose de spécifique dans
la société du point de vue de la culture
qu'elle fabriquait des repères qu'elle à
vous brancher les deux c'est la
mondialisation une économie extravertie
tourné vers l'extérieur ou avec les
phénomènes de concentration de
financiarisation qui vont avec la
mondialisation c'est une banalité
maintenant c'est heureux que ce soit
devenu une banalité de le dire créer des
gagnants et des perdants et ses gagnants
et les perdants se trouvait en plus des
gens qui en général pas tous ils sont
fait beaucoup mais quand même
majoritairement ou en effet
niveau de diplôme qui les sépare de la
société avec des phénomènes d'endogamie
des diplômés le patron épouse et sa
secrétaire maintenant il épouse une
collègue qui l'a connu hec ça change
tout
c'est plus le même le même univers et il
ya la ségrégation spatiale qui s'opèrent
en mêlant toussaint donc on essaie il ya
une nouvelle coupure que le système
politique n'a pas enregistré
les partis politiques sont devenus les
représentants de la france des diplômés
d'une manière ou d'une autre le parti
socialiste étant caricatural il parle au
nom du peuple mais il est là quand il
existait il existe encore une sortie à
oui il existe beaucoup plus qu'on croit
parce qu'il est un ski trust largement
le pouvoir local on oublie ce détail qui
est avec décentralisation et dans est
devenu un facteur extrêmement important
de la vie politique réelle du pays celle
qui touche les gens au quotidien
anne hidalgo et maire de paris on se
demande comment c'est possible quand on
skie comme à la présidentielle
c'est un fait dont il ya bien quelque
chose qui l'expliquent non pas supposer
qu'ils ont trouvée à une manière de
manipuler les urnes
particulièrement sophistiqué je ne crois
pas donc il faut bien a dû comprendre
les deux phénomènes mais il y a une
c'est ça la situation que nous vivons il
ya une effectivement une évolution
sociale qui crée une situation
parfaitement inédite où les gens qui
n'appartiennent pas à ces 25%
des discussions entre 20 et 25% très
savante chez les sociologues et
politologues mais des gens qui
n'appartiennent pas à ce monde-là
spontanément se retrouvent dans les plus
défavorisés des 75 % auquel ils
appartiennent moi ça va paraître est
logique est-ce que ça paraît logique un
oligo qui a été et est une élue et qui a
lui même quitté un grand parti qui
dépanne parti socialiste mais un autre
un autre mais c'est pas grave ça non
qu'on voit aujourd'hui
qu'il ya des nombres de livres rendez
les doléances où on appelle à rendre
tous ces cahiers de doléances qui ont
été écrits par des milliers de citoyens
pendant la crise des gilets jaunes quand
on voit le parlement européen ce livre
qui est sorti sur notamment toute
l'histoire de la convention citoyenne
pour le climat quand on regarde
démocratie rendons le vote citoyen donc
y parle notamment de ramener des
électeurs au vote plus facilement grâce
au vote électronique
on montre bien qu'il ya peut-être une
question de la représentation en fin de
compte est ce que les élus représente si
bien le peuple est ce que le peuple se
sent représenté par c est là et là où je
rejoins sur monsieur gauche et c'est sur
la question de la méritocratie et
aujourd'hui c'est effectivement toujours
les mêmes personnes qui se présentent et
moi j'aime bien le terme des rites au
cra ci parce qu'en fin de compte on
retrouve les mêmes couches sociales qui
se présente et je peux comprendre que
les citoyens ne se sentent absolument
plus représenté d'où l'intérêt peut-être
de rentrer des nouvelles formes et c'est
ce qu'ils appellent le peuple moi je je
je prône et là je sens un libre le
niçois y en a mais c'est intéressant
parce que ça va dans le sens ça montre
bien que le peuple a aussi envie de re
rentrer dans des bas d'une autre manière
parce qu'il considère moi je considère
que les politiques on a des sportifs de
haut niveau on peut avoir des politiques
de haut niveau mais si vous regardez les
couches de l'administration les couches
des élus nationaux
la représentation du peuple n'ayez pas à
l'époque c'était les partis politiques
qui représentait ça vous étiez
communiste vous représentiez telle
classe sociale socialiste en les
socialistes alors qu'ils étaient plus
proches des artistes il y avait il y
avait des déterminants et le jeu pour
moi a été totalement brouillé notamment
avec l'arrivée
des manuels macron avec le ni droite ni
gauche et la promesse justement que ce
soit un petit peu différent et peut-être
aussi avec cette société qui s'est un
petit peu aligné ses roues effectivement
on ressent mois des couches sociales
différentes donc je crois sincèrement qu
effectivement c'est un problème de
représentation avec des personnes qui
peut-être au lieu de jouer
leur ego e géo devraient jouer les égos
ega eu x
autobus que cette fracture on l'a elle
recoupe pas tout à fait le pays légal de
pays réel que ça me ramène dans une
archéologie maurrassienne on est dans un
autre âge à notre temps mais on la
retrouve partout
ses bras c'était les régions oui il y
avait plus que lionel bah oui depuis le
pays légal c'était la république fermé
c'est pour ça que cette cette opposition
est un peu frappé de péremption mais
c'est pas grave en tout cas elle est
parlante et suggestives on la retrouve
de fait en amérique entre by des névés
trump on la retrouve en angleterre entre
les bris sitter et des autres on la
retrouve en france on la retrouve à peu
près partout donc elle dit quelque chose
de très puissant de très fort c'est que
les peuples sont trop les peuples
majoritaire donc ce qu'on appelle
communément en france depuis que guy lui
à labelliser le ter la france
périphérique se sont affairés risée ce
sens à visibiliser se sent pas
représenté
et de fait en france on regarde les
chiffres de la désindustrialisation elle
affecte surtout la périphérie vers le
lit un bouquin de vermeren c'est pas la
france sur le déclassement la france qui
déclasse ouvert leur haine nous dit qu
on a perdu 2 à 3 millions dans le port
industriel en france hors saison point
du seraient ils n'ont pas été perdus ils
ont été perdus certes dans la petite
couronne la grande couronne et
principalement dans les villes de la
périphérie donc c'est ce sont des
univers sinistrés qui ne sont pas
représentés on le retrouve david
goodheart les samoa r&d any where c'est
donc c'est vraiment un paradigme qui qui
dessine les géographies les oppositions
les fractures surtout politique à peu
près dans tous les pays de l' ocde en
tout cas la france la france incluse et
ça fonde entre autres le malentendu si
je puis dire des élites un vis-à-vis ou
lentilles populisme des élites vis-à-vis
de ces de ses périphéries qui vote
massivement populiste
je pense que le l'opposition élitisme
populisme
associés à cette stratification
éducative était quelque chose de tout à
fait pertinent et qui a joué à plein à
la dernière élection présidentielle que
les votes maquereau et le pen était
négativement corrélé à un niveau
exceptionnel pour un statisticien et ça
ça ressemblait effectivement si c'est
passé pour le bras existe en angleterre
ou aux affrontements aux états unis mais
là en ce moment on n'a pas les résultats
on n'a que des sondages on n'a que des
impressions mais je suis en train de me
demander si on n'est pas en train on
n'est pas en train de passer dans une
autre phase encore où l'opposition
élitisme populisme elle même est en
train de s'effondrer c'est quand on dit
moi je me marre a ajouté ben maintenant
tout le monde est de droite ya plus de
gauche
vous via plus rien en fait je pars et
quand on regarde le l'évolution des
intentions de vote pour macron être est
très intéressante dire que la dernière
fois
comment dire le discours de malraux
c'était le style barré boutade minable
un discours anti populaires explicite
qui ravissait les agrégés de magritte en
2017 2017 oui effectivement quand on
regardait les résultats c'était très
stratifié par classe actuellement sa
part au niveau éducatif sa reste vrais
pour les intentions de vote pour le
rassemblement national sauf que ses
intentions de vote ont baissé que cet
exposé par le fait même lourde et quand
on regarde maintenant les intentions de
vote pour macron en fait c'est très
très sain distingue sur le plan social
c'est que si on le met à
25%
en moyenne ça passe là on va le trouver
à 27% chez les éduquer supérieur on va
le trouver à 20 21 chez les ouvriers
et
ya un moment donné où il faisait une
percée très élevé chez les
éduquer supérieur à complet pour une
raison mystérieuse
laisser les écoles c'est que les éduquer
supérieur incomplet basse et le cil dog
vachon a donc de mon temps à ça n'existe
en fait j'ai vite aussi beaucoup de dire
antenne 2
pour suggérer je me suis adapté
mais donc il ya un élément indistinct
donc
et donc on a un système qui se
pulvériser mais ça c'est pas
universelle c'était que ces français
français hésiteront cemac rond oui pas
là et tu peux expliquer parce que moi
j'ai pas j'ai juste lu ça et je dis
c'est que l'opposition élitisme
populisme n'est plus le truc pertinent
dans le moment mais dans le moment alors
ça peut être l'explication la plus
simple c'est de dire que ba
macro maintenant au stade actuel c'est
le parti de la peur et de l'état c'est
leur en fait on connaît la dangerosité
sonné
par le cos vide
et puis quand même
ce ses 25% supérieur
que te décrivait très justement comme
favorisée par la globalisation
ils commencent à en prendre pas mal dans
la descente social eux mêmes et est-ce
qu'ils sont tellement supérieure et est
donc vraiment
c'est la réaction de marcel gossio parce
qu'on va faire une petite pause après
très vite je crois que macron est un cas
politique exceptionnel c'est un
président qui a changé d'électorat en
cours de mandat
dépuis nîmois ce qui est rare ce qui est
n'arrive pas souvent certaine stabilité
il a les deux crises majeures qui l'ont
affecté qui ont affecté la france lui
ont donné un nouvel électorat les gilet
jaune leur nom fait le gardien de
l'ordre et il a ramené une partie de la
droite la plus classique dans son giron
et le co vide lui a valu dix ont des
sympathies social démocrate parce que
effectivement le quoi qu'il en coûte
le travail le télétravail etc tout cet
ensemble de protections sociales
exceptionnelles que nous avons eu
d'épidémie lui à lui vaut la
reconnaissance d'un électorat
légitimiste tout à fait traditionnelle
est en partie un électorat de gauche qui
n'était pas un électorat populaire pas
un électorat editis tu es je crois qu'il
va ce qu'il fait que home objecté
toujours vous avez commencé c'est vous
parler d'un échec que alors qu'ils
risquent d'être et il a les grandes
chances d'être élu justement bien des
échecs qui sont des réussites
volontaire est ce que ça veut pas une
société qui a été vraiment complètement
divisé vers le bas atomisé et où la
fonction dernière de la politique
politique de l'état c'est l'état de rops
c'est-à-dire d'assurer un minimum de
sécurité de stabilité jamais en général
absolument rien je suis entièrement
d'accord
juste un mot oui je pense néanmoins que
ce clivage perdu parce que là la
question migratoire qui la question
vraiment clivante et qui découpe cessé
de france c'est 2 angleterre ces deux
amériques où ces deux italie reste
centrale il ya des gens mais sous
vincent en france pour le moment parce
que parce que il ya beaucoup de monde y
parce que dès qu'il aborde un silence
s'instaure parce que les gens ont peur
parce qu'on est dans le déni voire même
temps des lic là je vais faire une pause
on va croire que vous censure
ça y est bon et chuterait site est aussi
terrorisée pause
pas bougé des fiches
[Musique]
que demandent les peuples que demande le
peuple on continue ce débat avec
parcelles gauche et avec emmanuel todd
aurélie gros et françois bousquet ma
question suivante c'est je l'adresse
plus particulièrement marcel gaucher
c'est le peuple est il plus lucide que
les élites je vous adresse à vous parce
que vous faisait remarquer dont
plusieurs livres que le peuple avait
senti avant les élites que l'europe et
la mondialisation ne ferait pas le
bonheur des français en même temps le
peuple est persuadé que son pouvoir
d'achat a baissé depuis 40 ans alors que
c'est le contraire l'essence coûtait
plus cher il ya 40 ans qu'aujourd'hui le
pain coûtait plus cher étant dès que les
salaires n'était pas le même évidemment
les autos coûter plus cher
c'est un peu pareil avec la violence
sont est persuadé qu' on n'avait jamais
vécu dans une société aussi violente sur
monte à 40 ans étaient beaucoup plus
violent il y avait plus de moeurs qui
avait plus de crime et je vous parle pas
de l'hydroxyde chloroquine
c'est à dire qu'on a vu tout à coup des
gens qui ne savaient pas où placer leur
vésicule biliaire avoir un avis sur
l'hydroxyte leur ultime je ne fais que
citer claude malhuret un ancien ministre
de la santé alors est ce qu'on peut
faire confiance au peuple alors que il
refilé capable de refuser l'évidence
c'est une question tellement compliquée
qu'elle demanderait de l'ombre de
longues explications
il y à une lucidité particulière des
peuples qui n'est pas une intelligence
des forces et des situations
je vais sans sombrer dans le pédantisme
cité un bon auteur qui avait déjà bien
identifié le problème il s'agit de
pascal les peuples voit juste en gros
mais ils n'ont pas la connaissance du
détail et ce tous tout est dit hillbilly
voile nous il ya un sentiment a ressenti
qui est lié à là
aussi à l'objectivité de la situation du
pape il subit plus que les autres c'est
sa définition donc il a une sensibilité
particulière à des choses qui pour le
gens plus à l'aise dans la vie pour
toutes sortes de raisons sont loin ne
compte pas dans leur diagnostic mais
effectivement il n'a pas la connaissance
et c'est la visite une biliaire ans
après
il faut ou en a pas on se tait josé part
effectivement mais le il ya une
l'originalité de notre situation et je
vais rejoindre une nouvelle fois
emmanuel todd c'est que on a
l'impression du côté des élites parce
qu'il ya toujours eu dans les élites des
gens qui avaient cette lucidité
particulières qui les rangs des proches
des peuples et que les peuples sentait
même quand ils venaient de milieux de
très favorisés proche d'eux il y avait
une capacité qui s'est perdue de
discussions entre les couches sociales
contre le haut et du bas de nos sociétés
qui est mystérieuse qu'il faut peut-être
et qui renvoie à la stratification
éducative qui évoque emmanuel tonnes il
parle même si je me souviens bien d'un
crétinisme diplômés ou qu'il apprendra
beaucoup
qui s'accorde à l'impression que la
connaissance acquise il ya divorce
épistémologique en quelques sortes le
peuple et les élites la connaissance
acquise vous prive de cette lucidité
élémentaires qui tient à une expérience
sociale partagée
mnl oui enfin bref j'ai un peu évolué
sur les questions
c'est à dire que j'étais à ses dents
quand même au ban de masse riche par ses
bailleurs
on voyait bien que l'opposition à se
traiter à ben sur ses projets de monet
absurde
était dans les milieux populaires en
fait si on avait laissé juste le droit
de vote aux ouvriers on serait pas
on n'aurait pas perdu notre industrie en
gros quand même malgré tout ça aurait
été sympa
donc donc l'opposition élite absurde
peuple ayant une certaine forme j'ai pas
dire bon sens parce que ça part un peu
condescendant mai
2006 en s'amusant dirais-je que tu
disais que le chili ne souvient pu le
tuer des êtres lucidité de de lucidité
devant maintenant je
sais pas comment dire d'abord d'abord je
trouve c'est un peu de temps en temps
son principe d'égalité définir le peuple
supérieur aux élites
si on croit vraiment en l'égalité on
doit distribuer
la malfaisance sur toutes les classes
sociales
j'ai plus l'impression que c'est quand
tu as évoqué une situation où des gens
d'en haut arrivaient à écouter parler
aux gens d'en bas qui pour moi c'est le
moment de moi j'associe l'émergence de
la démocratie
démocratie intelligente et fonctionnant
à
l'alphabétisation universel sa
progression donc en tout le monde s'est
mis a été capable de lire et d'écrire
mais il y avait simplement en eau des
élites à ces minuscules en termes de
équivalent études supérieures et si les
gens d'en haut vous voulez avoir
république si on peut dire il fallait
qu'ils cèdent compte des gens d'en bas
et et la
tendance est à dire qu on avait eu un
moment
maximale d'intelligence en haut et en
bas la société et ses caps qui a produit
la stratification éducative dont tu
parlais
c'est ce repliement effectivement de la
strate supérieure sur elle même est un
phénomène de crétinisation part entre
soi
perception partiel seulement dans la
société où des gens ont été capables
d'oublier qu'il fallait produire des
objets pour vivre c'est comme ça qui
s'est passé avec la perte de l'industrie
voilà mais je pense pas que on pourrait
dire que quand on est entré dans ce
système j'essaye de négocier le peuple
le peuple a gardé un moment de lucidité
ancienne mais mais je dirais qu'il a été
ramené au niveau de ses élites et que
maintenant
mais qui se dit pas non on a je veux
dire ya cet aveu si un rapport
dialectique
entre les étapes et c'est juste pas
possible de d'imagés une société où
seulement des morceaux une estrade
fonctionnerait correctement et cetera
mais
d'ailleurs je reviens là sur ce modèle
de convergence finale
avec des élites qui n'en sont plus du
tout
pas pour moi le bac ronis béthune de
populisme en fait finalement de
voilà et donc je ne vois plus tellement
la distinction donc par exemple et puis
je te vois pas le peuple porteur de
valeurs
morales exceptionnelles que c'est par
exemple j'avais jamais décrits dans les
luttes de classes en france une une
cascade de mépris descendant dans la
société où les gens d'enrôler dipose
super méprisait les ouvriers mais les
gens des milieux populaires qui à leur
tour se mettaient à mépriser les
immigrés ou les enfants d'immigrés donc
je trouve que
non on est tous en train de tomber
ensemble aurélie grosse chute
démocratique si on peut dire et
d'ailleurs le niveau éducatif baisse
pour les enfants de toutes les
catégories sociales 1 aurélie quand il
ya des raisons d'être optimiste aurélie
kaci pour elie gros va-t-elle pouvoir
nous rapporter un peu d'optimisme mais
voilà on m'avait dit on m'avait prévenu
que ce serait très pessimiste que
c'était la fin du monde donc tout va
bien je suis dans la non moi je crois
justement quand on parle des élites qui
sont koei qui s'intéressent encore et
qui sont capables de descendre vers le
peuple et discuter on le voit d'ailleurs
avec les élus locaux souvent sont des
strates intermédiaires je ne parle pas
des élus nationaux mais vraiment des
élus locaux qui sont d'ailleurs
plébiscitées les maires sont plébiscités
par sont encore les élus ont qui les
citoyens ou encore confiance donc ça
montre quand même que ce n'est pas
totalement cassée par contre moi je
crois sincèrement en l'intelligence
collective moi je crois à la
co-construction citoyenne je crois
qu'aujourd'hui les citoyens ont preuve
arrêt accéder à une maturité citoyenne
et participer beaucoup plus au débat et
on le voit actuellement dans le débat
actuel si on parle des questions de
santé
vous rassure je vais pas parler du coc
vide on entend parler tous les jours
donc ça ira mais sur le système de santé
actuel qui a été notamment révélé par le
copil si on regarde tous les collectifs
et toutes les personnes qui se sont
investies pour trouver des idées
notamment les professionnels de santé
c'est assez exceptionnel et je suis pas
sûr que les élites seul et d'ailleurs
certains organismes comme la rs ou où
d'autres n'ont pas été capables de faire
fonctionner donc c'est bien que les
élites n'ont pas réussi parce que les
élites c'est pas que les élus c'est
aussi la haute administration les
technocrates et je crois qu'il faut
s'appuyer de plus en plus justement sur
cette intelligence citoyenne et faire
émerger des idées et met ça en
construction moi je suis plutôt
positives sur auxerre bouscule gaucher
citer pascal je vais citer aristote sur
les vertus du nouveau
site et que manu rées
mais bon aristote c'est comme c'est le
père de la théorie politique s'il reste
important pour nous aussi et aristote
disait la chose suivante et qui plaide
en faveur du choix majoritaire du choix
populaire c'est qu'il est plus facile de
corrompre quelques gens en l'occurrence
une élite que de courant pour beaucoup
de monde et de fait cette loi mécanique
se vérifie
c'est plus dur de de tromper une
majorité mais j'aurais tendance à vue du
paysage assez sinistré de la baisse de
niveau généralisée à me rallier au point
de vue de todd quitte à le surprendre
c'est que c'est que il ya une révolte
des élites contre les peuples il ya
aussi une révolte des peuples contre les
élites il ya des dégénérescences
toujours aristote toujours la théorie
politique la monarchie sous dégradant
tyrannie
l'aristocratie en oligarchie et la
démocratie en autocratie en pouvoir de
la foule il y en a l'impression quand on
quand on voit les candidats défient les
shebab a chez la nonna on s'interroge
est ce que eric zemmour ou jean luc
mélenchon il ya cinq ans aurait été
jaloux là j'en suis pas sûr est-ce qu'il
ya cinq ans et nous n'avons n'aurait pas
invité mélenchon les zemmour ni marine
le pen ils vont y aller donc on
accompagne une baisse de niveau de part
et d'autre je pense que néanmois cette
fracture dont je ne connais aucun doute
à l'heure entre les deux français la
france d'en haut et la france d'en bas
s'accentue s'accroît ce sont ce sont
deux mondes l'amérique est très
révélatrice pour nous le monde de troy
ne peux pas parler au monde maiden et
réciproquement sarko n'est donc pas dans
une configuration guerre civile où on la
met en tout cas d'autisme de part et
d'autre on ne s'entend plus on ne
s'écoute plus j'ai évoqué le bouquin de
fourques et cassé lycée fascinant ce qui
montre le décrochage entre la conception
de la culture savante dans les
métropoles et de la culture populaire
dans la périphérie le rapport à la
baguette on peut évoquer la france tout
à l'heure la baguette est centrale dans
l'imaginaire français et notre relation
à la baleine baguette c'est ce qui monte
c'est vraiment c'est très amusant c'est
que la baguette à 29 centimes d'euros
chez leclerc passer un choix de la
france périphérique nous ont fait un
autre choix et on a du mal à se
comprendre a du mal à se parler comment
faire pour renouer du dialogue comment
faire pour que parce qu'un peuple sans
élite est un peuple morts mais des
élites son peuple sont des élites martin
et desséchées comment faire pour renouer
le dialogue entre eux entre cessé ces
deux univers de plus en plus étanche
elle a aimé dalton vous dit j'ai
d'ailleurs ça m'intéressait que
même les élites sont en train de devenir
populiste vous aviez l'air venir contre
onze on portera sa main avant j'étais
embêté parce que je trouve pas de grands
auteurs à six
sites et vous vous même non non je pars
la tête comme le chou fleur à ce
point-là tombé et il ya une chose dont
on n'a pas parlé quand même qui est
spécifique on l'a on parle vraiment
alors on était d'accord sur le fait que
le peuple français existe toujours mais
il faut aussi régler la question de
savoir est ce que la nation française en
tant que nation indépendante est capable
d'actions indépendante existe toujours
et là la réponse est non c'est à dire
que on est dans une construction
européenne
avec des réglementations commerciales
qui échappe au gouvernement on a une
monnaie qui échappe au gouvernement on a
un gouvernement d et donc est donc une
classe supérieure qui a perdu sa prise
sur l'histoire donc donc quelque part si
on définit sud si on se sont définis
très généralement ceux d'en haut et ceux
d'en bas par l'idée de domination il n'y
a pas eu aucun doute les gens d'en bas
sont des dominés mais en fait nos
énarques sont des dominés alors il ya
débat pour savoir s'ils sont dominés par
l'allemagne ou par l'amérique ou si la
france est devenue un condominium
germano américain mais en vérité on a
une à une classe supérieure certainement
avec des privilèges mais on a plus de
classe et légendes gêne un peu joueur
donc
on a un certain sens c'est normal que
c'est que c'est parce supérieur
crétiniser
je dire et qui ne contrôle plus rien
wihr populiste eux aussi sont dans une
sorte de rejet de la réalité de voiliers
mais ils ont quand même saluer sa vérité
pas la question je voulais vous poser
après c'est qu'on voit de plus en plus
nos dirigeants ce que vous venez de
décrire comme utilisant une rhétorique
du mauvais citoyen on entendu avec le
président de la république emmanuel
macron parle en disant qu'ils allaient
ils avaient l'intention d'emmerder les
veilles les non vaccinés parce qu'il est
conscient comme de mauvais citoyens et
de donner l'exemple enfin vous voyez on
a vu jean michel dentaire opposé au les
tenues républicaine
qu'il conviendrait de porter au lycée il
fallait l'opposé au nombre et à l'air au
mini jupe et au dos et au décolleté
avant pour être un bon citoyen il
fallait juste respecter la loi
maintenant il faut se soumettre aux
valeurs républicaines je sais pas ce que
sont les valeurs républicaines mais
visiblement un monarchiste ou un
anarchiste n'est plus un bon citoyen on
a l'impression de plus en plus nos nos
dirigeants quand il brandissait des
valeurs républicaines veulent nous
autres faire entrer en religion
ce serait une nouvelle religion la
religion républicaines auxquelles nous
en voyons tous soumis à défaut nous
serions de mauvais citoyens vous
ressentez ça passe à gauche et je
ressens c'est pas particulièrement la
qualification de mauvais citoyens c'est
le remplacement du jugement politique et
de l'autorité politique qui va avec par
la morale qu'est ce qu'un mauvais
citoyen c'est effectivement quelqu'un
qui est moralement condamnable dans son
comportement
les anti vaccin étant l'archétype le
concentré de cette faute morale il y en
a il y en a beaucoup d'autres il ya eu
qu'un long 4
mais là c'est la perte de la politique
c'est la perte dans le sens de la part
du président de la république du sens de
sa fonction quand vous vous dites je
vais en vrd mon voisin je vais pas
emmerder les gens qui belize ya quelques
jours qu'ils collent pas dans le
discours il n'assume pas sa position il
se met au niveau des gens qui l'ont
désigné comme celui qui va les conduire
qui va gouverner c'est ce mélange de
moralisme et d'incompréhension de ce
qu'est la chose politique me paraît la
vraie caractéristiques delà de la
situation avec la confusion totale que
ça introduit et en effet qu'il n'est pas
des plus rassurantes sur la capacité
même de nos dirigeants à comprendre ce
que veut dire le fait de gouverner et la
position que ça implique et le type de
discours que ça suppose moi c'est ça qui
m'inquiète le plus
c'est des élites c'est d'une autre
manière de retrouver ce que disait et
emmanuel todd qui ne savent plus ce que
c'est que leur rôle dans la société et
ce que veut dire la conduite d'un pays
religiosité ou pas religiosité
républicaine
il donne à voir oui à base de bois pour
moi c'est des mots 1 c'est à dire ce que
pas là
je pense que l'une des choses sur
lesquelles on est d'accord il passait le
gaucher c'est l'importance de la matrice
religieuse dans tout ce qui nous arrive
en fait à l'origine est pour moi une
partie de la du mystère de la situation
c'est que tout ce qui a existé de
collectivités de sentiment national de
système de parti et est sorti de
la matrice religieuse qui englobait
toutes les classes qui fondait la
société en fait qu'il a fallu un
millénaire d'histoire cher pour créer
puis il ya eu la déchristianisation qui
a libéré le concept de nation qui s'est
substituée à la collectivité chrétienne
et puis partis politiques et puis et
puis on vit un processus ultime de
dégradation de disparition
ces deux saisies des collectifs anti
collègues identité collective et donc et
dont on est dans un monde tout à fait
atomiser c'est tout à fait compatible
avec l'hypothèse de la stratification
éducative qui explique d'ailleurs la
rupture finale de la religion et dans ce
monde complètement atomisé les gens
achètent des mots vertu républicaine
je sais pas quoi d'autre ont pas manqué
lors beaucoup de leur valeur si un type
vous parle de valeur c'est le signe
clair qu'il en a très peu
le jeu qui pensent à autre chose géant
si on a des valeurs on les y vit on n'en
parle pas c'est comme la confiture la
blague sur la confiture et donc donc
voilà mais j'en viens ça c'est que
vraiment on est en train de je pense de
vivre le résultat ultime à part le point
d'aboutissement 2 de l'enjeu de
l'absorption de la france en tant
qu'entité politique nationale et c'est
dans la construction européenne qui a
été de fait au départ contre les milieux
populaires par des classes supérieures
qui croyait savoir où ils allaient et
qui ont fini par découvrir aux
comprendre un peu tardivement que
c'était leur propre anéantissement
et effectivement ils ne savent plus
pourquoi ils sont là je suis je dit
classe dirigeante est là pour diriger
mais s'il ya pu rien à diriger mais même
en politique internationale
actuellement on vit une période quand
même historique intéressante où on se
demande s'il peut y avoir la guerre en
europe
tout le monde parle de l'ukraine sera
donc aux adhérents en fait la décision
doit être prise par charles ce bras par
macro donc le droit à un certain niveau
c'est normal que notre président se
permettent d'emmerder les français si
lui même va simplement faire ce que lui
dit
2faire chose vous voyez il faut voir
l'ensemble quand même ça bousquet je
vais avant de répondre à deux questions
génériques un mot sur ce que vient de
dire emmanuel todd ce bien quand même
une très longue trahissent tradition
jaillir de trahison des élites en tout
cas de fascination pour moi de
l'étranger depuis 18e c'est assez ancien
le politique se réinvite rem
régulièrement heureusement sur la scène
de l'histoire sur cette question de la
république moi j'ai toujours en tête ce
mot féroce provoquant de baudrillard qui
disait de la démocratie que c'était la
ménopause des sociétés occidentales le
mot est un peu fort mais là donc c'est
sûr mais oui oui c'est la république
c'est
où la démocratie c'est un peu ça la
démocratie on en parle depuis l'attentât
en particulier c'est quand même de
manière incantatoire c'est la religion
la démocratie on aimerait rappeler de la
république on aimerait rappeler à ces
gens là que jaurès disait que la
république n'était pas un dogme
et comme je suis dans les citations
houellebecq qui nous dit que la laïcité
morte la république est morte quand le
tchétchène tue sa mère pattie tue pas la
république il s'attaque à la france à la
france des croisés quand les poilus va
dans les tranchées en 14-18 eelv
important de la république la république
on prend la partie pour le tout on pèche
par métonymie de la république n'est que
la forme
qu'a prise la france pendant une période
historique qui est la nôtre demain ce
sera peut-être une autre forme politique
que la république donc il ya une
antériorité de la france vous parlez aux
gens de la france a donc à assam sort je
peux te comment l'assassin de sa vie le
pâtis il sait ce que c'est que la france
c'est la france catholique la france des
croisés c'est elle qui l'attaquent mais
quand il m'a nouvelles têtes quand par
don manuel valls
[Musique]
quand manuel valls a ou blanc caire
blanc caire pour aussi revenir à blanc
blanc caire
nous serine nous bassine avec la
république c'est un ersatz et le
problème de la république passe et
l'a321 public c'est sa difficulté à
créer du sacré c'est que ça a sacré un
sac un simulacre de sacrés au calme
franchement je connais peu de jambes je
le connais peu de gens qui en dehors des
cercles politiques attendez il ya bien
une paye à une teinture extraordinaire
aller au louvre la république était
quand même mais signifie qu'ils ont
représenté sur que aurait les gros va
être correctement voulait se finir je ne
dis pas qu'il ya pas eu sous la iiième
justement parce que la 3ème république
par l'éducation s'est inscrite dans
l'histoire française au long cours dans
les grands hommes dans la grande
littérature aujourd'hui tout ça on l'a
perdu donc la république ressemble de
plus en plus une macro station un peu
creuse en tout cas moi c'est comme ça je
l'aperçois aurait les gros amas de façon
plus pragmatique et sans faire de
citations je dirais que
notre bon président emmanuel macron a
plutôt feinter pour éviter de prendre
une décision dans ses paroles qui font
le buzz et qui excite tous les
journalistes de la terre de france et de
navarre sur ses excès de langage souvent
ça cache une décision qui n'a pas voulu
prendre comme la vaccination obligatoire
ça évite de mettre en place la
vaccination obligatoire si on regarde
les mesures de monsieur blanc caire sur
les tenues à l'école ça cache peut-être
d'autres problématiques qui se situe à
l'école
l'école et qui justement avec des tenues
qu'on ap qui sont plutôt dirigés vers
les le sexe féminin oui généralement et
avec quelques problématiques qu'on peut
trouver dans le milieu scolaire
notamment après les événements de sa
belle pâtit je pense que c'est pour
éviter de parler des sujets qui fasse
donc pour moi tout ça c'est un manque de
courage politique donc ses excès de
langage c'est un manque de courage
politique
on ne veut pas dire la vérité ou
français vous n'avez jamais utilisé des
valeurs républicaines voulant tenter lui
c'est un truc un peu commode en ce
moment on évoque les veilleux le
parlaient de sya pas fait ça tout le
temps amis mais je suis pas marié ne va
pas se ressembler non merci le souci
c'est peut-être un réflexe à un moment
on est sur l'estrade on parle au citoyen
qui va se répéter tout le monde d'accord
ça qu'elles les ai dit sont aussi mal vu
et qui a une défiance et qu'à un moment
donné ils ne sont pas courageux ils ne
vont pas jusqu'au bout et ne parlent pas
franchement ce pensée et ils mentent aux
français c'est ce qu'on a reproché au
début de la crise sanitaire avec
l'histoire il faut pas porter de masque
bon je crois qu'aujourd'hui
vous êtes tous très bête maintenant on
en a donc on peut les entendre médiator
même dehors
une question de courage politique sur la
vaccination et on va emmerder les
français si quand on est président de la
république
mais quand on est élu maire d'une ville
moi je me dit pas toute la journée dans
mon bureau tiens je vais aller emmerder
les caudrésiens comment je vais faire je
mette ne masque obligatoire
je leur faire le pas sanitaires là où
c'est pas obligatoire pour cacher autre
chose il vaut mieux parler franchement
discuter échanger mais avoir des
décisions claires ce qu'attendent les
français c'est aussi des décisions
claires et pour moi ses excès de langage
sont pour moi du manque de courage
politique
des mots parce que ça va être la
deuxième partie mais ils restent non
mais en fait qu elle vraiment frappant
c'est de cette discussion sur les
valeurs alors que
on revient dans un monde assez simple
finalement sur bg les jaunes ça nous a
appris que le niveau de vie baisser sans
discussion possible et contrairement à
ce qu'on raconte qu'il ne sait depuis
des années
le belize 40 ans vous êtes d'accord que
le oui je discutais par les quarante ans
mais non mais qu'on soit bien clair sur
40 ans il a augmenté sur eux sur les 2 3
ans la vie et sur les dernières années
louis s'est dit c'est qui racontent
n'importe quoi bon et qui va continuer
sans doute et et ensuite il ya eu le coc
vide où on a pu remarquer en direct les
insuffisances de notre appareil
industriel on a pu constater qu'il ya
toutes sortes de choses fondamentales
qu'on ne pouvait pas fabriquer
maintenant si on regarde les nouvelles
économiques on enregistre des pénuries
pénurie de bois aux pénuries de puces
pénurie de tout on arrive à s'inquiéter
avait juste titre de poussée d'inflation
d'oka une urgence économique je veux
dire donc parler la vérité sur les
valeurs républicaines dans un contexte
d'effondrement de nos capacités de
production s'est vraiment pas l'urgence
on est on est on en est plus à des
questions de valeurs et donc et la
personne et est là pour essayer de
boucler
je voudrais parler du peuple boucle est
bouclée parce que ça oui mais c'est à
dire que les il ya bien des moments où
ils ont essayé de parler d'industrie
même macron a fait des bruits sur
l'industrie un moment et ça n'a pas
accroché dans l'opinion ce qui accroche
dans l'opinion ça n'est pas les
questions identitaires et d'immigration
mais c'est la question du pouvoir
d'achat et donc actuellement la sagesse
populaire et quand même pris en défaut
parce que les gens s'inquiètent du
pouvoir d'achat mais semble avoir perdu
de vue le fait que avant d'acheter et de
consommer il fallait produire et donc
peut-être peut-être que là
la stupidité et l'irresponsabilité des
élites a fini par éduquer le peuple a eu
certaines
stupidité équivalente bien deux côtés on
a quelques exemples concrets de sociétés
qui ont fermé je pense notamment à la
société bridgestone
dans le nord qui les salariés ont alerté
les pouvoirs publics sur une situation
avec des solutions concrètes on a alerté
et un an après ça totalement fermé
moyens et ses câbles de voir qu'il y
avait des solutions de terrain contester
ce que vient de dire emmanuel todd si la
question du pouvoir d'achat a été
déterminante et seulement l on
expliquerait pas le basculement vers
certes sondagier des opinions à droite
donc je suis si on néglige bien souvent
elles si alors c'est au dessus les deux
articulations c'est laurent bouvet moi
me semble utile qu'ils avaient raison
c'était la sécurité évidemment social
qui est déterminante surtout dans la
périphérie mais également une insécurité
culturels qui expliquent le basculement
à droite la droitisation surprenante
parce qu'aujourd'hui c'est la gauche qui
devrait gouverner en france avec le
l'effondrement de le déclassement la
désindustrialisation l'effondrement du
pouvoir d'achat c'est la gauche or si la
gauche dépeint au pouvoir c'est qu'elle
occulte cette dimension centrale qui est
la question de culture elle je vous
arrête là parce que c'est la fin de la
première partie je dis ça pour ceux qui
sont hors garde train de regarder cette
émission à la télévision il suffit de
basculer sur les réseaux sociaux pour
l'avoir voir cette deuxième partie qui
commence dans un instant avec de
nouveaux invités qui vont venir
s'ajouter aux précédents
pour ceux qui vont atteindre merci de
nous avoir suivis et rendez vous au
prochain numéro
[Musique]
et bien je vous présente tout de suite
mais deux nouveaux invités carragher
ahmad roy politologue vous enseigner à
l'université ningen aux pays bas
candidate déclarée à l'élection
présidentielle d'espoir rick 2022 une
association qui milite pour remettre les
institutions au service du citoyen vous
êtes l'auteur du référendum d'initiative
citoyenne expliquer à tous co écrit avec
raul manie berton et deux pour que voter
servent enfin c'est par uche et alma et
à gauche nicolas framont sociologue
rédacteur en chef de la revue en ligne
frustration est l'auteur avec céline
derkaoui de la guerre des mots combattre
le discours politico médiatique de la
bourgeoisie c'est paru aux éditions du
passager clandestin
alors on a abordé les problèmes de
l'élite on va aborder les problèmes du
peuple et avant de parler de l'anomie
démocratique parce qu'évidemment c'est
ça qui est récurrent
nicolas froment peut-être l'égalité sks
que dans les problèmes du peuple est ce
qu'il ya une demande d'égalité que
demande le peuple est ce que c'est
l'égalité est ce que est ce que vous
avez l'impression évidemment je me
poserai à tous la question est-ce que
vous avez port et l'impression que le
peuple souffre d' inégalités c'est
difficile de dire ce que demande le
peuple et moi je me méfie de cette
posture parce que souvent en fait on se
sert d'eux ont décrit ce que pense le
peuple pour mieux faire avancer son
propre agenda politique moi évidemment
je vois dans les demandes du peuple des
signes de ce que moi aussi je souhaite à
savoir une société plus égalitaire une
société sans classes sociales une
société qui ne soit pas basée sur
l'exploitation du travail d'autrui et
effectivement du coup j'en vois des
signes on a besoin de voir des signes de
ce qu'on pense politiquement gens voient
des signes dans les grands mouvements
sociaux qui ont agité le pays depuis
plusieurs années j'envoie dessine dans
certaines enquêtes d'opinion sur
sur ce que les gens estiment juste en
termes de répartition des richesses et
qui est bien en deça de la situation
actuelle en fait ces enquêtes d'opinion
elle montre plutôt que le niveau
d'inégalité sociale actuelle il est
plutôt pas toléré et de façon vraiment
très très répandue c'est pas du tout une
attitude minoritaire mais ça ne se
traduit pas tout à fait politiquement
donc ça c'est toujours un peu
désarçonnés et du coup je serai j'aurais
bien des difficultés à vous dire que le
peuple veut une société sans classes ou
une société communiste évidemment même
si je sois très fort mais ce que je
crois quand même c'est que on est arrivé
à un tel stade d'inégalités que plus
personne n'arrive à justifier l'état
actuel de répartition des richesses et
actuel d'exploitation du travail l'état
actuel de 2 aussi de mise à bas du
travail de perte de sens et je pense que
la plupart des gens en fait dans leur
vie individuelle dans leur vie intime
ressentent la violence du système
capitaliste le ressentent parce qu'il
est plus violents qu'avant parce que
comme ce qui a été dit tout à l'heure
bien on a une classe dominante qui
respectent moins
les classes laborieuses qu'avant pas
parce que selon moi elle est moins au
courant mais simplement qu'elle a moins
peur qu'une classe dominante une bonne
classe dominante c'est une classe
dominante capper or là elle a moins peur
et le moment il revient à la raison
c'est quand on saccage ces beaux
quartiers mais le reste du temps elle se
sent pousser des ailes la rega
l'émission le type de l'émission il est
révélateur que veulent les peuples
c'est quand même une question alors
elles reflètent l'état quand même de la
démocratie dans notre pays puisque on
est 6 sur un plateau parisien entre nous
à nous demander que peuvent-ils bien
vouloir s'il pouvait exprimer au moins
les revendications qui leur tient à
coeur on se poserait pas cette question
et c'est pas alors j'entendais dire les
questions de sondage se trouve suppôts
litho log les sondages on pose la
question qui qu'on a envie nous de
connaître dont on a envie de connaître
la réponse on pose pas la question que
les citoyens se posent il faudrait que
puisse poser les questions à leurs
concitoyens et mettre à l'agenda les
sujets qui leur passaient pas le cas
donc on ne sépare en fait ce que pense
le peuple écoutons le laissons le avoir
le pouvoir de faire des propositions et
on saura et dans certaines sociétés on
le sait sur la question de l'inégalité
en fait une égalité massive factuel
c'est une inégalité de pouvoir ou quand
même on est dans une situation
aujourd'hui où on a une majorité de
citoyens qui subissent les décisions
d'une minorité
leur on peut les qualifier d'élite mais
une minorité de responsables qui eux
exercent la totalité du pouvoir et le
décalage est de plus en plus fort
pourquoi parce qu'aujourd'hui la
majorité gouvernementale il faut le dire
c'est 13% du soutien du corps électoral
donc on a une majorité qui se tait sans
rien dire qui essaye d'aller dans la rue
qui n'a aucun moyen d'inverser le cours
des choses alors qu'elle subit une
totalité de des décisions auxquelles
elle n'a pas pris part qu'elle peut pas
inverser le cours des choses donc si on
parle d' inégalités oui une inégalité de
pouvoir très très fort très massives et
c'est ça qui structurent aussi la
politique dans des démocraties
représentatives qui ont poussé leurs
dérives oligarchiques jusqu'au bout
la france est un exemple mais c'est pas
le seul pays c'est peut-être celui qu'a
cette dérive la plus marquée notamment
en europe occidentale mais c'est pas le
seul à subir cette cette distinction là
donc ça c'est un constat de fait on a
une majorité des citoyens qui n'exerce
pas le pouvoir qu'ils n'ont pas le
pouvoir de prendre des décisions
j'entendais parler de co-construction de
des changes de discussion d'écouté c'est
pas ça la question la question c'est
comment on fait pour pouvoir que pour
que les citoyens puissent
décidée on a parlé du mouvement des
jeunes on n'a pas parlé par employé un
seul mot sert c'est quand même un des
rares mouvement social qui s'est centrée
sur une réforme institutionnelle et
c'est rare qu'un mouvement social ne
reste pas sur la revendication originel
et bascule sur dire ce qu'on veut c'est
contrôler les règles du jeu donc nous
voilà le mouvement qu'on a mis en place
la vision à laquelle on aspire c'est
qu'on soit qu'on sorte d'une société où
la majorité subi qu on puisse avoir
vraiment la possibilité pour chaque
citoyen de porter des propositions qu'on
a et des responsables politiques qu'ils
arrêtent de parler au nom de qui disent
ce que veut le peuple mais qui agissent
au service du peuple et responsables
politiques moi je l'entends au sens très
large s'est pas uniquement les élus
c'est aussi et bien ceux qui sont
titulaires de la fonction publique c'est
aussi les agents de l'état qui font leur
travail au service no2 et non plus au
nom en représentant maladroitement avec
leurs boules de cristal en disant où il
bascule plutôt à droite alors on va
parler de l'as rome ou la bascule plutôt
à gauche alors qu'on laisse enfin
l'expression de la diversité d'opinion
qui a dans notre pays s'exprimer et on
constatera bas que la crétinisation va
s'arrêter assez rapidement parce qu'en
disant décide eh bien ils se montrent
aussi en compétences de façon très forte
objectivement il ya une inégalité de
droits à une égalité de pouvoir elle est
criante et elle est l es l et criaient
aussi dans les rues il faut pouvoir
l'entendre cette inégalité la sael
gauche et alors nous revenons
effectivement à une situation historique
tout à fait intéressante où la question
de la nature de la démocratie et reposer
on avait l'impression depuis dix ans la
fin du grand mouvement ouvrier
que la démocratie représentative et est
devenue la formule accepté
vu les dérives dont vous nous parler
il faut pas s'étonner que repart f la
question d'un démocratie directe
la question centrale des régimes moderne
il ya une oscillation entre les deux est
une tentative temps de trouver des
formules participative délibérative qui
permettent de d'associer les deux
effectivement le mouvement des gilets
jaunes vous avez absolument raison adams
et à reposer cette question par an plus
une formule très particulière qu'elle
référendum puisque la démocratie directe
on connaît au xxème siècle dans le
mouvement communiste d origine c'est les
soviets les conseils ouvriers ça a donné
une famille politique le conseil isme
qui a des lettres de noblesse là c'est
pas ça c'est l'inscription dans un
système auquel on renonce d'exercer le
pouvoir en fait
le pouvoir en tant que tel parce que le
référendum prend des décisions il faut
que des gens les exécute on revient à la
notion de pouvoir exécutif conduit à la
mise en forme quand on est dans un
système de référendum d'initiative
citoyenne
avec l'initiative étant le point
important d'ailleurs parce
qu'effectivement il ya des référendums
mais qui pose la question
il faut un référendum sur le référendum
préalablement pour que la formule soit
résolu soit efficiente
mais on est en fait devant une nouvelle
une nouvelle étape de la démocrate de la
revendication démocratie directe dans un
contexte où effectivement le
les la question de l'égalité revient par
la question de la domination par la
question du pouvoir ça j'en suis tout à
fait d'accord parce que le ou les
inégalités en tant que tel à l'intérieur
d'un corps social sont relativement
accepté dans des proportions
un objet de débat on fait même des
économistes conseiller de construire une
grille de kehl et l'inégalité salariale
tolérable à 13,7 giro par exemple tout à
fait intéressant comme démarche donc
c'est pas l'égalité radicale mais les
cons l'inégalité devient une inégalité
qui se traduit dans l'impuissance des
arts au profit de la puissance des
autres on change de cadre c'est la
transcription politique des inégalités
qui est le vrai problème de démocratie
la question s'est il ne suffit pas du
référendum l'initiative citoyenne parce
que en réalité et c'est là où s'arrête
le gilet jaune
pour en avoir discuté avec quelques-uns
qui avait pris une question à coeur je
me suis aperçu c'est qui exécute les
décisions prises par le référendum
d'initiative citoyenne et on reprend un
problème de régis politique classique
parce que ses revendications
si justifiée qu'elle soit suppose un
agenda suppose des hiérarchies suppose
un dd à calendrier et il faut mettre ça
en forme et on revient à un régime de
démocratie représentative
donc on est on est dans une tension
nouvelle ses comptes probablement qui va
donner des résultats mais il faut bien
se dire qu'on est très loin d'avoir la
formule magique qui répondrait à tous à
mon sens est belle oui ça je suis
d'accord secondes je suis en train le
très conservateur ce sur ce plan là mais
je prends pas la démocratie directe je
crois à une collaboration des élites et
du peuple corse est choqué et
extrêmement banale sur le sujet mais
quand même
pour essayer de réfléchir enfin je crois
qu'on est tous sensibles à un certain
état de
un mélange de mécontentement et de
passivité
du corps des citoyens sans de paradoxe
qu on a parlé du déclin des croyances
collectives de ce qui fait que de la
nation et de tout ce qu'on veut mais il
ya quand même
quand même j'ai été des bobos graff un
petit niveau et je veux dire aussi avoir
une représentation concrète et
démographique de ce quel citoyen c'était
que une philosophie politique qui
s'applique à un corps des citoyens dont
l'âge médian est de 25 à 30 ans c'est
tout c'est une philosophie politique
mais là on est dans des démocraties où
l'âge médian du corps électoral est
supérieure à 50 ans et donc comment
s'étonner de ce qui a peu
de deux maux au niveau de la
d'accélération dans la prise de décision
c'est sûr même si les règles comment
dire si les procédures sont les mêmes ou
sont améliorées sont parfaites on sera
toujours confronté
à des démocraties très mature où le
niveau de vie reste très élevé mais où
le pouvoir électoral est donné de plus
en plus à des gens qui ne travaillent
plus qui sont consommateurs sans être
producteur alors ouais je commence à
avoir des doutes sur le suffrage
universel
vraiment je me dis faut-il garder le
suffrage je trouve que maintenant le
vieillissement du corps électoral donne
des arguments contre le suffrage
universel
d'en mettre dans mes moments de folie je
me dis on devrait supprimer le droit de
vote après 65 ans il est jeune car si
les jeunes grèce livrée si la
ligue est à ce moment là les jeunes
votre eau non mais ça suffira pas alors
même si tous les jeux c'est des jeunes
au bureau pour de bonnes raisons de ne
pas voter parce que il ya vraiment trop
de mecs comme moi
donc j'ai en fait je ne plaisante pas du
tout je viens c'est un vrai problème est
surtout que ça se produise
structurellement cette dissociation de
l'âge de la production et de la
consommation en fait et c'est alors
l'âge pour les bébés sont conservateurs
le programme
la notion de vieux consommateurs et donc
ça donne ses trucs ex-première ses
projets de réforme des retraites où tout
le durcissement du régime
doit peser selon le corps électoral à
ceux qui ne sont pas encore à la
retraite
c'est un des vrais dysfonctionnements de
la démocratie quand même tout le monde
est d'accord pour enfoncer des jeunes et
puis dans les cas d'épidémie d'épidémie
ça donnera
je suis ravi qu'on est sauvé les vieux
énormément plus personnellement mais on
a quand même fichu on a eu une
expérience de puissance gérontocratique
pendant qu vide tout à fait
extraordinaire on a enfermé les jeunes
vous parliez très justement des gros
mots d'emmanuel macron pour cacher son
incapacité à imposer la vaccination bien
toi j'étais assez d'accord c'était même
super bonne idée mais quand même de la
vaccination obligatoire pour tous et
inutile
ce qui suit en la bonne mesure celle
avec cissé ce que l'italien fait c'est
la vaccination n'est plus de 50 ans sans
peut pas puisque l'âge médian du corps
électoral est supérieure à 50 ans et qui
va falloir obtenir
laquelle acquiescement des plus de 50
ans non vaccinés en commission ça manque
sa marque juste le manque de décision
parce qu'ils aiment ce serait les
vaccinations obligatoires depuis
longtemps pour le problème du
vieillissement de la démocratie et du
robuste notamment
désormais aux électeurs certains gros
main et ça plaît à certains électeurs
certains gros mots la provocation et
voilà ça a plu à certaines personnes
dans sa musique est la question que vous
soulevez là se pose également pour le
risque puisque si le rique va également
susciter un vote assure vote disons
des retraités de ja on a reconstruit
tracy direct des retraités on a
reconstruit un posteriori d'augmenter
gilet jaune à leurs hits que surgit sur
les ronds-points janvier en janvier un
ça va on l'a suivi de près à
l'instauration je peux parler des gens
se rapprochent
je ne suis absolument pas hostile un
orri qu'au contraire
il faut qu'on renouvelle corps et génère
la démocratie la démocratie
représentative alain dilemme depuis 250
ans et comment museler le peuple comment
museler la colère du peuple un peu
comment l'encadrer à travers des
garde-fous à travers des chants bretons
à travers des cours suprêmes des
conseils constitutionnels donc c'est un
dilemne que les pères libéraux de toutes
nos constitutions opposé il ya 250 ans
sauf que le rique demande du temps le
ritz est chronophage
beaucoup plus l'abstention des jeunes
certes mais l'abstention la plus massive
c'est des catégories populaires où vous
allez sur intermédiaire alors évidemment
les catégories populaires jeunes
s'abstiennent encore plus et pourquoi
s'abstiennent tel un pour un tas de
raisons là il faut du temps il faut être
un journaliste pour ce un prof que c'est
jusque ce que je suis moi j'ai du temps
pour me consacrer à sa l'ouvrier n'a pas
forcément de temps j'ai toujours été
frappé travaillant dans l'édition et
l'imprimerie de voir à quel point le
modèle coopératif intéressé assez peu
les ouvriers pourquoi parce qu'ils ont
un seul souci c'est aller remplir le
frigo c'est c'est la fin du mois
s'arrête le 25 pour eux donc ils ont du
mal à s'investir dans quelque chose qui
ressemblerait à adé référendum récurrent
est fréquent quand je sens plus tôt
alors évidemment on parle tous ou non du
peuple
mais en même temps on est comme une
chambre d'écho jeu après tout je suis
pas sûr à l'heure sauf évidemment qu'ils
allaient précédent bonapartiste il ya eu
il ya un modèle publicitaire de
démocratie plébiscitaire en tout cas de
régimes autoritaires publicitaire c'est
la plus haute 3,93 fait beaucoup
beaucoup d'heureux de référendum
quantité qu'il a gagné dans des
proportions dont on n'a pas idée
aujourd'hui je la veille de sedan ils
plébiscitent ces sondés plébiscitent ans
à 90% vous avez un corps électoral assez
importante 10 millions de gens qui vont
voter de quoi on a fait ça sur des
sujets régaliens je le conçois mais
après le je suis pas sûr que le jeu - si
je m'en tiens à ce que je vois dans mon
entourage dont la france périphérique
c'est un peuple qui cherche le bon
pasteur le bon guide il n'a pas le temps
la politique ça prend du temps c'est la
liberté l'opposition entre la liberté
des anciens et des modernes qui au coeur
de la démocratie directe la liberté des
anciens ça vous bouffe du temps il faut
aller sur l'agora il faut aller parler
il faut s'informer la liberté des
modernes passé la liberté d'être chez
soi d'allumer son bar 2 de mettre en
branle son barbecue de regarder la
télévision de se reposer c'est le oui au
rhic d'accord c'est d'abord une traque
des vieux qui iront voter que des inclus
que des preuves que des journalistes
nous les retraités on va tout le temps
mais je connais je crois je commence à
en être assez l'objection d'edgar morin
sur porto allègre alors lui défendent et
même au delà de démocratie directe à
démocratie participative des supers
démocratie participative mais c'est une
affaire de csp + mais ça je suis
d'accord mais c'est pour ça que le
rythme n'a rien à voir avec morteau
allègre ce que ce qui est quand même
assez ahurissant moi je dois vous le
dire parce que je travaille sur ces
sujets et j'ai la chance de passer une
partie de ma vie professionnelle aux
pays bas
je suis désolé de le dire le niveau
français sur la question du risque et de
la démocratie directe est bas et on a la
démonstration ce soir de la bassesse le
niveau sur cette question là pourquoi
parce que d'abord alors c'est la foire à
la confusion c'est à dire oui alors ça
prend du temps le aller au delà avec la
démocratie participative on parle de
deux choses complètement différentes et
la vente du riz c'est que vous pouvez
rester chez vous attendre tranquillement
aller voter quand ça vous va vous avez
juste un nouveau droit un droit qui est
celui d'écrire la loi quand vous en avez
envie ce qu'ils veulent dire ce qu'il
faut s'informer et d'investissement
personne ne vous demandera votre carte
de bonnes informé en entrant dans le
bureau de vote n'a plus aujourd'hui je
la connais c'est à dire hey hey hey je
crois je finis là dessus parce qu'au
fond c'est important de je suis ravi de
voir qu'on s'accorde quand même sur un
diagnostic qui est qu' on a une majorité
de personnes qui sont impuissantes et ça
produit mais j'ai envie de dire
heureusement une forme de 2,2 de désaveu
où on dit mais pourquoi je vais j'ai pas
continuer et je rejoins lac sur la
question de la lucidité mots j'ai écrit
un article pour savoir si les citoyens
étaient capables de percevoir la qualité
de la démocratie dans leur pays la
réponse est oui et quel type de citoyen
les perdants ceux qui sont jamais au
pouvoir ceux qui subissent au quotidien
des décisions au qui ne partagent pas où
ils sont capables mais vraiment aussi
bien que les experts devraient vous
partagez le papier ça vous intéresse
vous pourrez voir donc ça c'est
constallation les partage après avoir
démontré que le risque c'est la mesure
technique qui permet de mettre fin à ça
c'est facile parce que c'est une
question de fait et quand on parle de ce
que le riz produit de ce que produit pas
à minima il faut regarder les pays qui
le pratiquent il faut regarder moi je
rejoins ans s'inscrit dans le temps long
au début les grandes luttes pour les
droits civiques c'était des luttes
contre l'arbitraire c'était début de
ford et choisissez la constitution que
vous voulez mais donnez nous des règles
imprévisibles arrêter la tyrannie et un
roi des cils et puis d'un coup ça c'est
bien ça c'est pas bien ensuite on s'est
battu et les mouvements ouvriers parmi
les mouvements ouvriers parmi la classe
ouvrière il y avait le soutien pour la
démocratie directe de forme initiative
écriture de la loi vote de la loi était
très haut cités les appareils qui
suivait pas les partis ouvriers sur
cette question regarder l'histoire des
mouvements en suisse quand cette
question s'est posée les partis disent
ah nan nan nan on va pas aller jusque là
alors que le mouvement ouvrier lui
disais si si nous ce qu'on veut c'est
écrire la loi directement donc
maintenant on ouvre on est dans une
nouveau mouvement des droits civiques et
dans des mouvements de droits civiques
et bien on les voit en les parce qu'on a
les mêmes types d'arguments qui sortent
toujours les gens pas le temps il y aura
et d'ailleurs pour emmanuel todd ya des
façons moins radical que de supprimer le
droit de vote aux personnes âgées pour
faire voter les jeunes par exemple on
supprime on fait des inscriptions
obligatoires sur les salaires et sur les
sources et 4 à 6 et quand on fait de
bonnes raisons mais non mais vous
reprenez ya un débat générationnel entre
nos maux mais j'ai bien compris l'invité
d'un fragment est ce que là est ce que
la lutte des classes est soluble dans
l'eau risque le référendum d'initiative
citoyenne enfin ce qui est intéressant
c'est que le référendum d'initiative
citoyenne soulève des réactions qui sont
intéressantes et est ce que je trouve
intéressant ici c'est on voit comment il
ya une idéologie qui est reconduite qui
est celle de dire que dans le fond les
citoyens ont pas être trop intéressé à
la politique ils ont leurs propres
contraintes qu'ils doivent remplir le
frigo d'ouvrier il n'a pas le temps
en tout cas un ordinateur le congélateur
exactement à ces sons créés et du coup
bah voilà en fait la fonction des élites
c'est de reconduire un discours qui
prouve qu'on a besoin d élite et moi par
exemple je suis pas du tout d'accord sur
l'idée fait c'est une idée qu'on a par
habitude qui auraient besoin d'une bonne
collaboration entre le peuple et les
études puisque par définition l'élite
elle ne peut pas collaborer avec le
peuple parce qu'elle était à tes lettres
qui diverge alors du coup on essaie de
revenir en arrière on dit il ya eu un
temps où l'élite était plus respectueuse
etc etc et donc en fait on cherche
toujours la bonne et dit qu'ils seraient
intéressés par l'intérêt général alors
qu'elle est intrinsèquement intérêt est
intéressé par son intérêt de classe
parce qu'en fait l'élite c'est pas une
élite c'est une classe sociale dominante
alors c'est vrai qu'une fois qu'on ce
qu'on a cette grille de lecture là on se
pose la question de comment faire
comment faire et et moi comment faire
c'est pas comment assurer bonne
collaboration parce qu'il n'ya pas de
collaboration possibles dans une société
de classe c'est comment assurer un bon
rapport de force et le rapport de forces
c'est ce qui permet non pas de dialoguer
mais c'est ce qui permet d'imposer la
vue de ses intérêts et de les obtenir
par la force par la force par le rapport
de force veut pas dire forcément la
violence physique mais ça veut dire en
tout cas par utiliser ses ressources
pour faire plier l'adversaire parce
qu'il ya un rapport d'adversité et ç'a
toujours été le cas et moi je suis
toujours fasciné comme en eau construit
l'histoire a posteriori pour se dire il
ya eu un moment où le dialogue s'était
pas tant c'est pas du tout genre enfin
dans l'après guerre etc on avait des
grèves ouvrières hyper forte nos élites
et peut-être plus accommodantes parce
qu'elle avait peur et cette peur c'est
cet orient avec laquelle il faut renouer
c'est pas avec des bonnes capacités de
dialogue alors ensuite la question
institutionnelle elle pose les bonnes
questions parce que du coup elle permet
d'avoir le débat sur de quoi les gens
sont capables et c est moi je trouve que
c'est super intéressant le référendum
parce que c'est un révélateur et qu'en
réalité quand vous dites référendum vous
avez toujours des gens qui font partie
de la bourgeoisie qui vont vous dire oui
mais sont pas très informé oui mais ils
n'ont pas le temps pour moi c'est plus
révélateur des affects de la bourgeoisie
et en saas et passionnante parler du
référendum après moi je pense c'est une
mesure très nécessaire qui dans un
régime aurait beaucoup beaucoup
d'importance et beaucoup d'intérêt mais
au stade où on en est arrivé là ça me
semble est insuffisant parce
qu'effectivement la mise en place du
référendum nécessite donc une
technocratie toute une classe politique
qui est actuellement la classe politique
de la classe bourgeoise et de ses
différentes fractions c'est un fait
sociologique mesurables ne serait-ce que
la composition de l'assemblée nationale
ne serait-ce que l'origine sociale de
nos ministres et donc on peut pas
attendre de cette classe là qu'elle
mettre en place des outils qui sont
censés ensuite la priver de son pouvoir
là c'est ça le problème et c'est ça le
blocage auquel on a affaire c'est que on
va penser des outils institutionnels
pour améliorer la situation mais ceux
qui de vous doivent mettre en place ses
deux soutiens institutionnels n'ont pas
du tout envie de la changer ce qu'ils
veulent c'est revitaliser la démocratie
c'est à dire remettre des paillettes
dans les yeux de tout le monde
l'histoire qu'on y croit encore dix ans
de plus c'est haut niveau mettez ne des
paillettes dans les conditions
c'est votre job
cela était en vie sur le rique moi j'ai
la question du référendum pour moi c'est
pas la question du temps déjà dans les
réunions que j'ai menées un peu partout
sur le territoire pendant à peu près
cinq ans ce qu'il apparaissait c'était
plutôt un référendum à la suisse parce
que le problème du rich en l'espèce
c'est que souvent ça se transforme en
plébiscite pour ou contre le président
de la république ce qui est assez gênant
quand on pose une question si les
personnes se prononce pour ou contre le
président de la république ça n'a aucun
intérêt sur les référendum à la suisse
c'est un petit peu plus et un peu
différent puisqu'il ya plusieurs
questions de poser des questions
régionales départementales une question
nationale ce qui permet quand même
d'avoir des réponses peut-être plus
précise et plus orienté en fonction de
vraies convictions du citoyen mais après
sur la question juste un peu juste pour
être sûr oui le rique une c'est le
référendum à la suisse on parle pas du
nom mais si le référendum d'initiative
citoyenne celle de faire mal aux
éditions populaire et ce quelque chose
c'est juste que une personne qui est
dans le mouvement s'appelle mais dans ce
match on est bien d'accord ça reste de
la consultation puisque les questions et
nous est bien sûr que si puisqu'elle est
question ça fait pas c'est périlleux
renaissance c'était là c'est la capacité
des citoyennes de revenir sur les
règlements qui leur semble juste bien
sûr il s'est offert son initiative va
pas assez loin c'est à dire que c'est
pas de la co construction citoyenne
c'est pas le pouvoir d'amendement du
citoyen sûr qu'on va pas plus loin moi
ce que je propose du mois que les
citoyens proposent que je parle au nom
d'un collectif citoyen et d'une
association c'est d'aller beaucoup plus
loin c'est à dire de enfin mettre sur la
table installée à ce qu'on dit installer
les citoyens à table du gouvernement
c'est de proposer qu'avant toute grande
loi votée à l'assemblée nationale des
concertations soit lancé dans les
territoires alors vous allez me dire
c'est long bah oui mais bon regarder la
réforme des retraites ça a duré une
plombe l ai jamais sorti donc on aura
bien fait de faire une concertation au
moins on aurait eu la vie des citoyens
tout en leur donnant toutes les
informations et je parle pas des
informations gouvernementales qui bien
toutes les informations avec toutes les
orientations de tous les partis
politiques pour qu'ils aient le maximum
d'informations pour pouvoir décider
proposée qu'aux construire et donner des
idées citoyennes qui seraient ainsi les
citoyens
juste après oui je vais vous demander
votre adresse de permanence et puis je
vous envoyait le rique expliquer à tout
ce que vous allez lire ce que ça est ce
que ça veut dire exercé du nageoires
division dont certains sans vous parler
de la concertation ça ne va pas plus
loin puisque c'est un dispositif ou mais
pas les citoyens proposent des choses je
crois qu'il faut vraiment clarifier le
débat les citoyens peuvent proposer des
idées au final les élus choisissent
celles qu'ils retiennent le référendum
d'initiative citoyenne c'est les
citoyens font une proposition de loi il
la rédige il la voit directement et les
élus l'appliquent c'est pas de la
concertation les élus n'ont pas la
capacité pour qu'on 500 bien sûr que ça
l'est c'est jusqu'à non c'est pas de la
construction sous contrôle début de la
construction
et vous ramener commander les citoyens
au vote là bas quand ils peuvent décider
je vous assure que les citoyen vote et
je vous invite vraiment à regarder ce
qui se passe dans tous les ateliers qui
ont été mises en place ou les personnes
ont écrit des lois où ils appellent de
leurs voeux vraiment le fait de dire
nous ce qu'on veut pouvoir c'est porter
des propositions aussi avec nos élus il
n'y a pas d'opposition n'y a pas de
nécessité de dire oh les méchants l'a
peut-être qu'on a eu une divergence de
points de vue ou dans un certain nombre
de 15 cd travail il ya surtout avec au
niveau local on a des mères qui aimerait
bien pouvoir porter avec leurs citoyens
la proposition généralement ça ce qu'ils
font de leur village pas toujours mais
en a certains en tout cas qu'ils font ce
pas là leur emmanuel todd oui pour
clarifier le débat et pour être sûr de
bien comprendre je voudrais demander à
kara et bien si lerrick tel que le
conçoit
fonctionne dans le cadre de la zone euro
c'est dire qu'on regarde l'euro ou pas
nous le dit fièrement ouais merci on
regarde l'europe ne le risque qu'on
propose je vais répondre très clair le
riz qu'on propose c'est un rite qui
touche à la constitution serre qui
permet aux citoyens de changer la
constitution la constitution étant au
dessus des traités européens
les citoyens peuvent décider de sortir
deux ou même un pari mais vous même vous
êtes tous ou contre l'euro mais moi on
s'en fout ce à quoi je suis pour ou
contre on se présente à la
présidentielle maintenant présente sur
ds vous ne comprenez pas c'est que en
fait tant qu'on est dans l'euro aucune
procédure ne peut rendre au peuple sa
liberté donc enfin annoncé avant même
s'il propose elric il faut dire que vous
êtes hostile à l'euro
c'est le pipeau c'est faux c'est bon je
suis hostile heures faut
sortir du capital serait ce que pour le
fait
mais vous êtes conscient que c'est faux
de dire ça actuellement c'est sa vision
c'est sa vision mais c'est faux hier on
peut pas dire vous pouvez pas le mettre
en place puisque on peut pas mettre en
place un risque sur la loi ordinaire
rien ne nous empêche de modifier la
constitution
d'abord d'avoir ce droit-là en restant
mais si vous pensez que la question de
l'euro peut être discutée quand votre
grille c'est que vous-même n'est pas
clair dans votre tête sur les
implications a su ce qu'elle est c'est
tout non c'est du pipeau non pas du tout
c'est que moi mais je suis claire et là
il faut le dire un moment donné où je
suis né sur quatre et c'est normal on
s'en fout un trésor public dans notre
pays aujourd'hui je suis candidate à la
présidentielle est-ce qu'on peut il faut
quand même relire notre constitution le
président de la république représente
l'intégralité des français il ne
gouverne pas un président qui dit je
suis contre l'euro c'est un président
d'un camp politique dans notre pays
aujourd'hui à des personnes qui
souhaitent rester dans l'euro il ya les
personnes qui souhaitent en sortir le
rôle d'un président c'est que
l'intégralité de ses opinions puissent
s'exprimer et qu'il ya eu une décision
démocratique qui soit prise faut arrêter
et on n'a plus besoin d'une figure
monarchique il est allé avec mon bâton
de pèlerin j'vous sort de l'euro et puis
tout ira bien lisons quand même ce à
quoi les textes constitutionnels nous
contraignent alors peut-être nous dira
ah bah oui mais a minima en tant que
citoyenne moi j'ai la faiblesse de
penser que un citoyen qui se présente à
l'élection il a contrairement a
visiblement beaucoup de gens autour de
cette table et même vous emmanuel todd a
minima lit la constitution sur ce que
sont les pouvoirs du président est
capable de dire on s'en fout des
opinions personnelles président ce qu'on
veut c'est un arbitre c'est quelqu'un
qui lutte contre je suis désolé mais
quand j'entends la phase on s'en fout
des hôpitaux personne du président je me
dis je suis ou
dont marcel gauchet oui à écouter c'est
un coup de jeune pour moi cette vie que
j'ai l'impression de revenir au
lendemain de mai 68
on a hérité très exactement d'une check
et on peut pas dire que ça a donné des
résultats très probants sur l'instant
mais le chantier sur le fond mais est
totalement découvert et peut-être que la
discussion à une meilleure issue encore
que le rapport de force par rapport à
vos positions parfaitement un spectable
ne paraissent pas en notre faveur
puisque vous êtes pour le rapport de
force j'espère vous constatez que le
rapport de force vous êtes très
défavorable dans la conjoncture actuelle
aux classes laborieuses oui il est très
défavorable mais ça peut changer ça peut
changer et nous savons que l'histoire
nous réserve beaucoup de surprises ac te
ment
nous sommes dans une situation
complètement ouverte mais là vous pouvez
pas dire madame c'est pas sérieux de
dire qu'on souci ch des opinions du
président de la république puisque il
était lui parti d'un programme un nom
mais justement c'est la grande hantise
la fiction française
je dirais la monumentale b du général de
gaulle et d'avoir rêvé en pensant à lui
mais pas la france et aux français qu'
il allait d'un arbitre non
mais en théorie un arbitres mais là on
pratique un président est élu par des
partis assez puissant pour le soutenir
dans sa campagne électorale je ne veux
pas mésestimer bon sens mais je pense
que maintenant mais bien sûr que j'ai
très peu de chances mais je serais pas
allé enfin l'idée de produire une offre
politique qui tranche c'est de montrer
que c'est on n'a aucune aucune
démocratie occidentale aucune qui n'a
pas de figure d'arbitrage aucune la
figure d'arbitrage dans un système
politique elle est essentielle notre
constitution en prévoit une en pratique
c'est vrai elle est bafouée depuis quand
particulièrement depuis 2002 parce qu'on
a malignement des mandats l'inversion du
calendrier électoral et on s'est habitué
à entendre le président de la république
s'engager sur une série de mesures qu'il
ne peut mettre en place que si la
majorité à l'assemblée mais là c'est un
problème quand même quand quelqu'un se
présente en dix ans donnez moi tous le
pouvoir j'échangerais votre vie résultat
on n'a plus de fonction d'arbitrages
dans notre pays on l'avait
constitutionnellement la plus si vous me
dites pas ça va être dur de revenir en
arrière là dessus parce que la pratique
s'est instaurée je suis d'accord par
contre si vous me dites c'est du pipeau
deneux de d'exiger que les présidents de
la république ne soit pas questionner
sur leurs opinions personnelles ne
soient pas questionné sur ce qu'il
ferait sur l'emploi sur le pouvoir
d'achat mais ce qu'ils soient vraiment
questionné sur qu'est ce que ça veut
dire être un gardien de la constitution
comment vous allez faire quand le
gouvernement va vouloir passer au dessus
de l'assemblée est passé jean d'angély
charente
je veux le président finlandais le
président fera l'objet et telus est pas
prêt de le président de la république
n'est pas élu par les partis élus par
les citoyens et s'il ya d'autres il ya
d'autres pays l'islande la finlande
alors la finlande vous allez me dire
c'est vrai que c'est chaotique c'est la
finlande qui est quand même sur beaucoup
de classements internationaux très haut
en terme de qualité des droits
protection des droits qualité de la
démocratie système de redistribution
caisses du club il est dedans niveau
éducatif elle a un président qui élu au
suffrage universel direct et qui a des
fonctions d'arbitrage s'en moque et vous
avez un problème pour la démocratie des
rares à et alors vous allez faire quoi
mais c'est du boulot c'est du boulot si
on avait un arbitre aujourd'hui on
saurait ce qui se passe au conseil de
défense sanitaire aujourd'hui on
s'accommode d'une situation chaque fois
je discute avec des journalistes dit
vous savez ce qu'on débat ah bah non et
c'est pas faute d'avoir demandé à bon et
on s'arrête là on dit bah ouais et puis
on lui demandera son avis sur la bête on
vous imagine c'est très bien de parler
d'arbitrage
de toute façon en france l'arbitrage se
fait quand même dans la tête du
président de la république parce que il
est en réalité il est obligé de tenir
compte du rapport de force entre les
positions politiques des uns et des
autres et c'est pas une bonne solution
parce que je préfère que l'arbitrage
soit public et délibérée aux années dans
ses attendus ça c'est certain c'est pas
que je suis pas un fanatique de la
cinquième en public dans cet état mais
le ne peut imaginer
cela que
l'arbitrage suppose un processus en
amont
d'éclaircissement décompte de ceux entre
quoi il faut arbitrer c'est celle à la
limite du risque c'est qu'ils donnent
une décision mais il permet pas sur un
devoir les oppositions de fou qui
s'exprime dans la délibération
collective sur le sujet françois
bousquet on part de là crise de la
représentation le rique n'est que
quelques uns des modes possibles unique
une des réponses possibles parmi
d'autres mais c'est le problème c'est la
crise de la représentation le inutile de
rappeler le référendum de sur la
constitution européenne
55% des français près de 55% des
français le refuse 85% de la renconte à
sion nationale le plébiscite sous la
forme du traité de lisbonne donc on a un
gros problème de représentation les gens
ont un sentiment gîte main la preuve par
le tc eux d'avoir été dépossédés de leur
vote vous l'avez rappelé tout à l'heure
en 2017 quand on réunit les candidats
hors système aux populistes parce que
les deux l'été marine le pen et
mélenchon les deux se définissait comme
des candidats populistes vous rajoutez
dupont aignan est à 45 % des votants au
rliss la div c 4 % la représentation
nationale donc on a un problème lourd à
régler mais je suis pas sûr que le
risque soit une des réponses possibles
parce que là je pointe je pointe du
doigt une forme de démobilisation du
corps électoral qui a le sentiment de ne
pas être écoutés et la question qu'on
doit se poser qui qui qui doit devrait
nous inquiéter c'est la question posée
par la boétie sur la servitude
volontaire c'est que très long cours
dont la très très longue durée
citer les bozos des grands auteurs
surtout quand ils sont cuits là je n'y a
pas de problème transcanada on n'a pas
les flatter le don je sais que le seul
paradoxe de boulgakov l'auteur du maître
et marguerite il disait que le prendre
le problème de boulgakov
les disait boulgakov que le nom mais
folie il faut dire
que c'est pas la chose étonnante c'est
pas que les lettres les travaux et les
tramways de
ne marche pas c'est le ski était le
paradis c'est que ça marche ce sur quoi
on doit s'étonner aujourd'hui c'est que
les gens continuent à voter parce que si
on est habitués à voter depuis 150 ans
il ya une forme dans la très très longue
durée d'un différend tisme de
démobilisation des populations je règle
ce sont rabat mobilisés si vous leur
demandez moi je vais bien j'aime
énormément le modèle suisse mais c'est
un modèle qui est radicalement différent
du nôtre c'est par modèle catholique
c'est pas un modèle pyramidal c'est un
petit pays c'est un modèle où la
décision vient du baril remonte vers le
haut à les imposer ça quand un pays
latin et un pays catholique est pourquoi
pour pas en faire qu à débat sur le
rythme non plus je voudrais rappeler moi
aussi mais par une citation du général
de gaulle que l'élection présidentielle
qui approche il la voyait comme la
rencontre d'un homme ou d'une femme et
d'un peuple
c'est vrai que cette cette rencontre on
pourrait avoir l'impression que mon vote
une fois et puis après on en parle plus
pendant alors septembre au général de
gaulle maintenant plus que cinq ans qui
pose pas mal de problèmes d'ailleurs
mais enfin en gros qu'il y en a un qui
parle et les autres écoutent ya eu des
sondages depuis qu'il faut qu' il ya
quand même un dialogue permanent y
compris et surtout pendant la campagne
électorale où ils ont tous leur leur
sondage pour savoir ce que le peuple
veut entendre au fond je veux être leur
chef donc il faut que je les suive donc
lé sondage il y a il ya les réseaux
sociaux aussi s'ils sont quand même
bouillonnant autant on peut parler
d'elle d'ennemis démocratique autant les
réseaux sociaux c'est quand même la
foire aux opinions tout le monde se
manifeste alors vous allez me dire c'est
pas 60 millions de français c'est même
très très peu en comparaison qui enfin
ça bouge bien il ya le référendum il ya
vous votre proposition c'est que je sens
que ça c'est un symbole chansons pour
qu'on sait que la première décision est
la première action du président de la
blic le procès la présidente de la
république soit en direction des
citoyens et qu'il se rende au sommet
citoyen ne soyez toujours une première
action du président une fois qu'il est
élu donc c'est de faire des dégâts il
vient d'être lu par des citoyens il faut
qu'en encore qu'il aille voir les
citoyens tout le temps donc bah oui
c'est ça vous parler des réseaux sociaux
côté les réseaux sociaux ont montré
aussi qu'ils avaient une capacité de
mobilisation des citoyens grâce aux
réseaux sociaux alors ça peut être un
bien mais de temps en temps c'est pas
forcément un bien quand on parle des
fêtes news des fausses informations donc
je crois qu'aujourd'hui on peut s'en
servir des réseaux sociaux c'est très
bien mais il faut aussi que le citoyen
soit entendu dire ça que moi je reste
persuadé que la concertation le fait
d'aller vers les français dans les
territoires le fait de transformer le
conseil économique et social en conseil
de la participation citoyenne en le
fondant avec la cndp je pense que ce
serait intéressant d'avoir cette
troisième chambre enfin actif qui est
accessible aux citoyens je pense
qu'aujourd'hui il ya une maturité
citoyenne qu'il faut prendre en compte
d'ailleurs grâce aux chaînes de
télévision en continu grâce aux réseaux
sociaux qui ont permis aussi de
s'exprimer beaucoup plus habitués les
conventions et les conventions citoyenne
aussi copains mais malheur je voudrais
vous poser convention citoyenne sur le
climat qu'en oui au succès mais déjà
quand vous prenez 150 citoyens vous
pouvez pas vous êtes des spécialistes
messieurs mais 150 citoyens ça ne
représente pas les français ce n'est pas
possible d'avoir toutes les couches
sociales d'avoir d'avoir un sondage pour
ça il faut moi ce que je voudrais poser
moi je voudrais vous poser une question
plus largement c'est à dire que ok on a
dit le peuple veut le l'égalité mais
enfin bon il ya autre chose qui me
préoccupe c'est la liberté si nos
libertés se réduisent de plus en plus de
plus en plus je crois pas que c'est la
faute des gouvernements successifs qui
seraient de plus en plus autoritaire je
pense que si les gouvernements
successifs réduisent sans arrêt nos
libertés c'est pour faire plaisir au
peuple je pense que c'est le peuple qui
veut de plus en plus de sécurité et par
la même occasion de moins en moins de
liberté donc je me dis que tous vos
moyens les vieux un peu mais bon mais le
peuple le peuple veut la sécurité
sécurité économique sécurité sanitaire
sécurité toutes sortes il veut pas qu'on
lui prenne le peu qu'ils possèdent c'est
normal
et j'ai très très peur que en donnant le
pouvoir au peuple de quelques manières
que ce soit que ce soit par le rique là
on va nous réduire nos libertés d'une
phase de façon drastique
en permanence on ne va plus cesser
d'interdire des trucs et pourquoi cette
émission s'appelle interdit d'attaquer
parce que j'ai l'impression c'est devenu
une passion nationale
il ya quand même une autre
interprétation du durcissement de tout
ce qui est mesuré près civ de
bus de plus en plus central de
l'appareil policier en fait oui c'est
vrai c'est déserter là je pense que nous
on va tomber d'accord c'est que en fait
on est dans une phase de l'aggravation
des difficultés économiques
d'appauvrissement d'une partie de la
population
amenant à des choses comme les gilets
jaunes etc en fait la question de
la centralité
répressive dans les fonctions de l'état
se confirme de jour en jour donc devant
ce gouvernement je laisse à chacun ses
marottes un certain cédric dont celle
euros enfin
ce qu'on vous l'a appris hier et si on
croit comme moi que ne peut résoudre
aucun problème économique en restant
dans les réglementations commerciales
européennes dans leur eau etc on doit
programmer l'état pour un
appauvrissement accéléré de la
population des tensions sociales qui
s'aggrave et donc le seul truc que peut
faire le gouvernement effectivement
s'est perfectionnée l'appareil répressif
de l'état
c'est celle là liberté du maquereau
nisme c'est ça avec ce petit coup de
pouce que peut donner la lutte contre le
terrorisme ou les gens applaudissent
comme tu disais les mesures qui
permettent d'en fermer ou qui
permettront d'en fermer plus rapidement
déterrer des terroristes islamiques
supposer sans se rendre compte que les
gens qui seront concrètement enfermé en
masse plus tard ça sera à eux quand ils
se révolteront contre leurs conditions
de vie
nicolas froment mais je rejoins votre
analyse moi ce que je constate quand
même c'est que voyez vous dites c'est le
peuple qui demande les mesures
répressives sur l'impression quand il se
passe un truc bien c'est les élites ont
fait le bon choix et compère truc mal
c'est le mauvais peuple mauvais peuple
qui a fait lire hitler enfin c'est
toutes ces conneries historique pour
dire que finalement vous voyez un
argument plus or le peuple y veut
remplir le congélo haletant en plus si
on me demande de voter il va être
sécuritaire total des arguments c'est
sûr que ça donne pas envie de démocratie
et pourtant ce que vient de dire
emmanuel todd c'est vrai c'est pas le
peuple qui attirait qui a mutilé j ai je
ne sais pas le peuple qui a dit percuté
les ça les fera réfléchir au moment de
la journée de croix du 8 décembre à
paris ici même la demande de répression
ça d'abord été une demande de la classe
dominante parce qu'effectivement barrage
vaujour tout à fait ainsi ombre est
aussi on applique l'agenda de bruxelles
qui est l'agenda qui aussi voulue par
les socialistes français qui est aussi
voulu par macron donc voilà auxquels
notre caste dominante française est tout
à fait consentante c'est un régime
d'appauvrissement c'est un régime de 2,2
briser les protections sociales de
briser l'assurance chômage donc c'est
mettre des gens à bout et donc derrière
la réponse qu'on a elle est répressive
elle et psychiatrie zante parce que du
coup maintenant les gens sont en
souffrance donc on va aller
psychiatrisés leur souffrance sociale
c'est cesser france télécom c'est
derrière tout un tas d'experts qui vont
à essayer d'analyser la souffrance au
travail sans jamais parler
d'exploitation au travail donc on va
vers cette société de contrôle et elle
vient cette société de contrôle à vient
uniquement de l'an viii de la classe
dominante d'aller jusqu'au bout de son
agenda de voir la difficulté qu'elle a
parce qu'elle a ses difficultés quand
même parce qu'en france il ya les
mouvements sociaux y'a pas de référendum
mais il ya des mouvements sociaux et ça
reste quand même des cailloux dans leurs
chaussures le dernier en date c'était
quand même la réforme des retraites la
réforme des retraites la classe
dominante française le veut mais le veux
terriblement c'est une évidence pour
elle elle ne supporte pas cette idée
qu'on puisse payer des gens à rien faire
c'est c'est insupportable pour elle elle
veut briser ce système là elle veut le
faire en plus de façon technique elle
veut qu'ils aient plus de débat le
régime par points s'est il ya plus de
débat c'est chaque année y aura des
experts qui croiseront des courbes et
qui diront ah bah tiens faut travailler
plus longtemps parce que la conjoncture
le veut donc ça c'était leur idéal il
cherchera même de bouger le dire du
poids on trouvera c'était vraiment là
lors leur kif quoi c'était se dire il y
aura plus besoin doit même plus besoin
de passer par l'assemblée nationale ça
se fera au comité d'orientation des
retraites etc donc j'étais à ça à sa de
la voir et puis il ya eu des grosses
manifestations et puis bon il ya ulcos
vite donc aujourd'hui au vide sauvé par
le préfet que j'ai un moment de
tendresse pour le comité et c'était et
c'était un point fort est donc
maintenant ils veulent y repasser et
donc le voile à la diminution des
libertés publiques elle sera le fait de
la classe dominante et ça c'est très
important que ce soit bien cas je vais
pas dire les classes populaires je
voulais dire l'ensemble du peuple la
nation pour moi c'est les individus qui
veulent réduire les libertés des autres
en général par souci de leur propre
sécurité c'est les individus qu ont
beaucoup à perdre qui veulent réduire la
liberté des autres et ceux qui ont
beaucoup à perdre c'est plus sa classe
bourgeoise que les autres salles comme
tout serait simple si ça sera menée
bon affrontement classique qu'on a
appris à l'école quand j'étais petit en
tout cas enfin bien changé depuis
entre la classe dominante et la classe
dominée parce que le de la demande de
sécurité
elle est beaucoup plus large elle est
beaucoup plus profonde
la situation sanitaire c'est pas la
classe dominante qui pousse dans le sens
de la restriction des libertés fait
quand on m'a crosby après avoir bien
mûri la question n'est pas aussi
spontanément qu'on pourrait croire qui
va emmerder les antilles vague il répond
à une demande d'une partie de la société
et qui n'a rien à voir avec la classe
dominante nécessairement même si ça peut
se recoupent et il ya une demande de
sécurité pourquoi de beaucoup plus large
parce que nous sommes dans un monde qui
secrète une insécurité inédite à tous
les niveaux une insécurité majeur qui a
à voir avec la situation économique mais
qui est très nouvelle c'est l'insécurité
des jeunes générations celles dont jerry
manuel tonnes devant l'entrée dans la
vie elle entrait dans une trame dans un
travail nous il s'agit de se vendre soi
même ce qui relève objectivement de
mécanismes économiques et d'un nouveau
capitalisme ça c'est certain mais qui
touchent à quelque chose d'existant ciel
qui est beaucoup plus large que la
simple de que la simple volonté d'une
minorité d'imposer sa loi à la majorité
pour faire bien il ya quelque chose il
ya sais c'est qu'il faut être examiné
cette demande ont tous ses aspects et
vous un balcon si je prends cet exemple
au hasard qui se trouve que j'ai eu à en
connaître indirectement un balcon
s'effondre parce que des gens faisaient
la fête sur le balcon et donc plusieurs
morts demande aussitôt de toutes les
associations possibles addictions des
balcons
de réfection des balles co2 etc etc ces
quotidiens ces demandes là elle est
permanente
c'est le porter en particulier il faut
le dire par un parrain l'acteur mal
connus de la scène politique et souks et
le secteur associatif
inquiète a grandement d'heure de
sécurité dans tous les domaines dans la
presse de gauche une des cibles
prioritaires c'est les îles juridique
qu'est ce que les vides juridiques c'est
précisément les marges de liberté un peu
vaseuse qu'on n'a pas encore envisagé de
quadriller sérieusement et qui vont
toujours dans le sens d'une réduction
d'une liberté c'est cette demande de
sécurité par un état civilisation
humaine quand ben il faut regarder les
ya pas que les vieux
la question de l'ambivalence de l'état
qui est à la fois un état pour la
sécurité de tous celles et en europe ce
jeu leur place c'est un auteur quand
même un daniel rops non non non qu'est
ce que c'est que ce trois plaques se
connaissait tous ces trucs là je me dis
avec du xviie siècle quand même puisque
l'université même temps
sa maudite ya ça et puis il ya l'état
des marxistes instruments de classe mais
en fait il ya une ambivalence de l'état
et l'état est les deux à la fois on est
maintenant
je rejoins gauche et il ya beaucoup de
consentement dans cette question c'est
ce que le coc vie de montres on revient
à la servitude volontaire je suis désolé
écrit à
18h02 donc un jeune on doit s'interroger
sur vous ne tardez pas avec un verre
mais présente sa maison à
s'interroger sur ce consentement jeu
vers celle que nous dit moi j'ai rappelé
à la bioéthique du corona virus que nous
dit le corona virus c'est que l'on à la
société moderne la société consumériste
nous fait une promesse à wau homme je
vais vivre qu'à 76 ans de 77 ans
statistiquement femme je vais vivre
jusqu'à 80 82 statistiquement si je
meurs avant
tout qui a cloché dans le système donc
je demande à ce que le système c'est ce
que j'ai appelé la double outils du
coroner est en lice le système me
protège me surprotège en étouffant on
reste en restant en diminuant les
libertés et vous parlez des marottes je
pense que moi ce qui nous manque en jeu
j'insiste sur le congélateur je pense
que ces centrales le congélateur
mais c'est une obsession célinienne
pourquoi si on s'intéresse à la france
périphérique à la france de gilet jaune
pour de bon et pas de loi ce que nous
montre fourquet et casser les c qu'est
ce que font ces gens là c'est pour ça
qu'ils font pas de risque c'est que la
fin du mois se termine le 25 ils passent
leur temps à faire le plein le plainte
de la bagnole le plein du tabac à rouler
le plan du caddie et surtout le plein du
congélateur il ya un mythe tenue
congélateur elle roland barthes écrire
dans la france périphérique dans la
france pas millionnaire bat donc ça
chacun sa marotte sablon si on veut
parler de cette france là dans des
catégories populaires et des classes et
faut s'intéresser à la baguette à 29
centimes pour s'intéresser au
congélateur c'est le congélateur
l'obsession c'est le congélateur pas le
rique le mois s'arrête le 25 novembre
son désaccord avec vous c'est pour ça
que l'égalité est inacceptable c'est
pour ça que le fait d'être si peu
rémunérés de son travail peut aussi voir
petit quelque chose qui a été dit répété
par les jeunes et qu'il l'ait dit et
répété par tout le monde et on parlait
de la question de leur sécurité mais
vous dites il ya moins il ya moins de
sécurité en fait social donc les gens
veulent de sécurité via les flics non
les gens veulent aussi de la sécurité
collective or c'est ça qui est en train
d'être démantelé quand on détruit
l'assurance chômage c'est la mesure la
plus insécuritaire qui ait jamais été
prises ces dix dernières années
quand on détruit l'assurance chômage ont
détruit une sécurité qui vous permet de
pas et complètement être esclave de
votre destin professionnel de palettes
complètement de l'aide beaucoup mais pas
complètement donc on détruit la sécurité
sociale et c'est la plus grosse mesures
assez sécuritaire qui était prise et on
nous dit qu'au contraire on va vers du
sécuritaire mais non on va vers de l'ain
sécuritaire et on compense sa part du
sécuritaire d'opérette qui est à voir
des flics et des patrouilles vigipirate
qui défilent pour rassurer le bas peuple
qui a besoin d'être assurés non le bas
peuple il a besoin de s'assurer
collectivement c'est ça qui se passe les
gros et clara hughes est à mon sens
c'est aussi une question de consommation
de services publics c'est à dire
qu'aujourd'hui le citoyen veut tout on
l'a vu dans les vaccins par exemple en
france on avait quand même le choix de
choisir quel vaccin vous alliez sur une
plate forme alors moi je dis modern en
francs et du finder en troisième je
prendrais de l'astra zelekha quand il
était encore bon avant qu'on me dise
qu'il est pas bon donc et après la faute
aux tendres c'est pour ça qu'on est dans
une réduction des libertés aussi sert
comme le dit marcel gauchet le balkan
tombe pour le peu que ce soit un
logement social c'est la mairie qui sera
en cause ou la mairie ou le bailleur ou
le constructeur qui vous voulez mais il
ya une forme de
déresponsabilisation et de
surconsommation qui réduisent pour le
coup à mon sens les libertés et je parle
bien quand on parle de sécurité à tous
crins sécurité dans tous les domaines
parce qu'après sur la question de la
sécurité de l'insécurité puisque vous en
parlez ça reste aussi un sentiment qu'il
a peut être nourri souvent par les
réseaux sociaux les chaînes de
télévision en continu qui crée aussi une
forme d'insécurité chez le citoyen la
surinformation créé à mon sens
l'insécurité images moi j'entends ça je
me dis on vit pas dans le même pays en
fait j'entends les gens veulent du pain
et des jeux mais pas de droits du pain
et des jeux il faut manger et puis
s'amuser et à trans écurité moi j'ai pas
vu pendant la crise sanitaire de demande
très forte de d'un surenchérissement de
mesure j'ai plutôt vu en tout cas ce que
j'ai pu voir parce que comme tous les
autres observateurs de la vie politique
j'ai été contrainte de regarder la
pétition des manifestations où c'était
plus tôt pour avoir une relâche des
mesures que allez on y va et on y va à
fond ce qu'on observe et jeudi c'est
pour ça que je dis je n'avais pas
l'impression de vivre dans le même pays
c'est que quand on regarde les enquêtes
sur les valeurs dans le temps long les
enquêtes européennes sur les valeurs
qu'est ce qu'on observe dans le temps
long et on observe que la demande de
liberté elle est très très forte qu'en
france les skis la défense des choix
individuels la tolérance vers des choix
aussi de vie différent de pouvoir faire
société avec des personnes qu'ils
opteraient pour des vie de couple d'une
certaine mesure pour une restriction
aussi de l'arbitraire d'état pour une
vraie méfiance vis-à-vis de la
surveillance des nouvelles technologies
elle monte à l'effort elle est aussi
forte en fait que parmi des pays qui
sont sur ces sujets on va dire des
populations qui sur ces sujets sans très
très vigilants je pense par exemple aux
pays qui se veut être plus libéraux les
pays bas on a vraiment quand on voit ça
ce qui est effarant c'est qu'on a
l'impression et je vais faire une image
qui parlera je pense à tout le monde que
on a des français qui ont des opinions
de suédois de finlande est très civique
très droit et qui sont gouvernés par des
responsables bulgares qui disent non
l'état la verticalité il faut leur
donner du pain des jeux de la sécurité
les droits ça les intéresse pas alors
que c'est parce que c'est on a plein de
données pour le dire c'est pas ça qui se
passe par contre ce qu'on voit là c'est
que et bah ya une difficulté quand même
accepter que ce petit pas alors fut la
danse et on abat c'est un petit pas moi
je veux j'applaudis des deux mains c'est
d'ailleurs par c'est quand même
condorcet qu'a inventé le dispositif du
référendum ni cette histoire fx place
quelqu'un il fallait j'ai placé personne
fallait que je passe quelqu'un mais qui
et qui a permis aux suisses de l'avoir
fait à lire c'est vraiment et de tout
moment dans l'histoire quand on a eu des
demandes droits civiques des demandes de
pouvoir on a eu en face des
intellectuels et des responsables
politiques ont dit on va vous proposer
autre chose aux demies imaginer que si
quand les femmes se sont battus pour le
droit de vote on avait dit ce qu'on va
faire écouter bien pourra faire une
commission tirés au sort de femmes qui
va nous expliquer ce que les femmes
veulent parce que les jeunes n'ont pas
le temps comprenez bien les femmes n'ont
pas le temps elles sont au foyer elles
doivent remplir le congélateur elles
peuvent pas et c'est ça les intéresse
pas des cibles mais on dirait mais
partout en regardant d'un air dur qu à l
époque on n'aurait pas dit on aurait
trouvé ça normal ces bateaux là
24 ans je remercie tous les 6 devant
participer à ce débat je vous remercie
de votre attention d'être venu jusqu'ici
en dépit des risques afférents
merci encore merci de nous avoir suivis
et rendez vous au prochain numéro
[Musique]